I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. And today we are going to be talking all about Oscar Martinez. And we are really excited because we have Oscar Nunez in the studio
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你们制作终极版《办公室》粉丝播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。我们是《办公室女士》6.0版。今天，我们要聊聊奥斯卡·马丁内斯。我们非常兴奋，因为奥斯卡·努涅斯就在演播室里。
today answering all of your questions about his character. I've been looking forward to this one. Well, it turned out great. Spoiler alert, we had the best time with Oscar. We had the best time. So here's what we're going to chat about. He's going to answer questions about the office and the paper, which has its season two debut on Peacock today, September 9th.
今天他会回答所有关于他角色的问题。我一直很期待这一期。嗯，效果非常好。剧透预警，我们和奥斯卡度过了一段最美好的时光。我们玩得太开心了。所以，这就是我们要聊的内容。他将回答关于《办公室》和《纸》的问题，该剧于今天，9月9日，在Peacock平台首播第二季。
But first, we're going to share all about Oscar. Jenna, you're going to discuss the show Bible. We're going to talk about Oscar favorite moments. I'm going to share three. her personality traits that fans say they love about them. It's good stuff, lady. All right. Why don't you go first?
但首先，我们要分享关于奥斯卡的一切。珍娜，你要讨论一下剧集圣经。我们要聊聊奥斯卡最精彩的时刻。我要分享三个粉丝们说他们喜欢的他的性格特点。这可是好东西，女士。好了，你先来吧？
Sure. So I haven't been in the show Bible in a little while. Because we haven't done one of these all abouts. Was it dusty? You know what? Can I tell you? I have been using my digital version of the show Bible. I found it in my digital clutter.
当然。我已经有一阵子没看剧集圣经了。因为我们有一段时间没做这种“关于某人”的专题了。它上面落灰了吗？你知道吗？我能告诉你吗？我一直在用我的电子版剧集圣经。我在我的数字杂物里找到了它。
Look at you go, girl. I know. I thought you would be proud of me. I'm proud. I said, is it dusty because that's something my mom would say, like, if you go into someone's house and their Bible's dusty. Oh, that is so funny. I haven't been to church in a bit. I like that. Okay, well, so first of all, every time you have a character name, it will also tell you their address. Now, if their address has been written or scripted as part of the show, they just have the address. But if their address has been made up by the art department, it says per the art department. So Oscar has a per the art department address. Which means it was never used in the universe of the show on camera.
看看你，姑娘。我知道。我以为你会为我感到骄傲。我很骄傲。我说“它落灰了吗”是因为那是我妈妈会说的话，比如，如果你去某人家里，发现他们的圣经上落满了灰。哦，那太搞笑了。我有一阵子没去教堂了。我喜欢这个。好吧，首先，每当你有一个角色名字时，它也会告诉你他们的地址。现在，如果他们的地址在剧中被写过或编入剧本，他们就只有那个地址。但如果他们的地址是艺术部门编造的，它会写着“根据艺术部门”。所以奥斯卡有一个“根据艺术部门”的地址。这意味着它在剧集的世界里从未在镜头前使用过。
Right. He did have one. He did. And also what they would do, I had this and we all had this, they would make us wallets, credit cards. Driver's license. And they would put this address on those documents until they were told otherwise. I'm so curious if when Dwight is sneaking around spying on office. Oscar and Gill if there was the address on the house.
对。他确实有一个。他确实有。而且他们还会做的一件事是——我有这个，我们所有人都有这个——他们会给我们做钱包、信用卡、驾照。他们会把这个地址印在这些证件上，直到他们被告知换掉为止。我很好奇，当德怀特偷偷摸摸监视奥斯卡和吉尔时，房子上是否有那个地址。
Oh, that's a good question. I bet the number on the house does not match this address per the art department. Let's see. What was it? It lists his address as 1327 Pear Street. Oh, Pear Street. Mm-hmm. All right.
哦，这是个好问题。我敢打赌房子上的号码和这个“根据艺术部门”的地址不符。让我们看看。是多少？它列出的地址是梨树街1327号。哦，梨树街。嗯哼。好吧。
I am looking up Oscar and Gill's house, and the numbers on the house say 5232. Mm-hmm. So that is a deep cut fan catch right there. Yep. And, you know, that house was in Van Eyes. It's on a lot of people's drive and find office spots. Yes. So was not 1327 Parr Street. Was not. But if Oscar opened his wallet, that's what you'd see. Oh, hey, everyone. By the way, Sam just found us the Google Maps for 1327 Parr Street and Scranton. And it looks. looks like an abandoned something called rush hours. Sam, did you say it looks like a bar? Yeah, it looks like a former bar. Yeah, it has no trespassing signs. A long time ago.
我正在查奥斯卡和吉尔的房子，房子上的号码写着5232。嗯哼。所以那是一个非常资深的粉丝发现。是的。而且，你知道，那栋房子在范奈斯。它在很多人的“寻找《办公室》取景地”的驾驶路线上。是的。所以不是梨树街1327号。不是。但如果奥斯卡打开他的钱包，你看到的会是那个。哦，嘿，大家。顺便说一下，山姆刚刚帮我们找到了梨树街1327号在斯克兰顿的谷歌地图。看起来……看起来像是一个叫“高峰时间”的废弃场所。山姆，你是说它看起来像个酒吧吗？是的，它看起来像个前酒吧。是的，上面有禁止擅入的标志。很久以前的事了。
Well, there you go. Did we just mom detective that? I think we did. Well, we Sam detected did. We did. Thank you, Sam. But in true mom detective form, there's no real answer. No real solution. It is what it is. It is what it is. All right, well, digging into what the show Bible says about Oscar, there is not a lot about his family of origin, but we do know a few things. We know that his parents were both born in Mexico. They moved to the U.S. a year before Oscar was born. So we know that Oscar was born and grew up in the United States. We know that he has a nephew. He also has an aunt that lives in Carbondale, and we know that his mother is now in a wheelchair. We know that Oscar speaks Spanish.
好吧，就是这样。我们刚刚像妈妈侦探一样破案了吗？我想我们做到了。嗯，我们山姆侦探做到了。我们做到了。谢谢你，山姆。但以真正的妈妈侦探形式来说，没有真正的答案。没有真正的解决方案。事实就是这样。事实就是这样。好吧，深入挖掘剧集圣经关于奥斯卡的内容，关于他的原生家庭信息不多，但我们确实知道几件事。我们知道他的父母都出生在墨西哥。他们在奥斯卡出生前一年搬到了美国。所以我们知道奥斯卡是在美国出生并长大的。我们知道他有一个侄子。他还有一个住在卡本代尔的阿姨，我们知道他的母亲现在坐轮椅。我们知道奥斯卡会说西班牙语。
but he is not good at doing accents. You know, when we're doing the murder mystery, he tries to do the accent. He's very, very bad. Very bad. We know that Oscar has a timeshare in Key West and he drives an SUV. We also know that Oscar likes yoga, long lunches,
但他不擅长模仿口音。你知道，当我们做谋杀之谜游戏时，他试图模仿口音。他非常、非常糟糕。非常糟糕。我们知道奥斯卡在基韦斯特有分时度假房，他开一辆SUV。我们还知道奥斯卡喜欢瑜伽、漫长的午餐，
and is one of the founding members of the Finer Things Club. He's pretty physically fit since he can pull himself up into the ceiling during the fire drill and he likes doing ab work. Mm-hmm. He is also a very good ice skater. and he hates posters of babies playing jazz. That's one of the things he very much disliked.
并且是“精致事物俱乐部”的创始成员之一。他身体素质相当不错，因为他在消防演习时能把自己拉进天花板，而且他喜欢做腹肌训练。嗯哼。他也是一个非常好的滑冰运动员。而且他讨厌婴儿演奏爵士乐的海报。那是他非常不喜欢的事情之一。
Very, very much not a fan. When Oscar was younger, he wanted to be an actor in commercials. But as you know, he ends up in the accounting department at Dundermifflin. We don't really know how he got from aspirations of being an actor to becoming an accountant. And we do have a very fun conversation with him later about who exactly is the head accountant. Or who he thought it was going into it. And in season four, he says he's been at Dunder Mifflin for nine years, but in season five, he says he's been at Dunder Mifflin for eight years. Oscar, do the math, buddy.
非常、非常不喜欢。奥斯卡年轻时想成为一名广告演员。但如你所知，他最终在邓德·米夫林会计部工作。我们真的不知道他是如何从演员梦变成会计的。我们稍后会和他进行一次非常有趣的对话，聊聊到底谁是首席会计师。或者他进入公司时认为谁是。在第四季中，他说他在邓德·米夫林工作了九年，但在第五季中，他说他在邓德·米夫林工作了八年。奥斯卡，算算数吧，伙计。
He also owns a little Dunder Mifflin stock, we come to find out. And his nickname in the office is actually. We know that Oscar is gay. He has a longtime boyfriend, Gill. And when they break up, he becomes interested in Matt from the warehouse. And then he eventually begins an affair with the senator who is married to Angela at the time. State Senator. State Senator. And then Oscar announces he has plans to run for state senator, but we find out that instead he ends up in the accounting department of a small Toledo newspaper.
我们还发现他拥有少量邓德·米夫林的股票。他在办公室里的绰号其实是……我们知道奥斯卡是同性恋。他有一个交往已久的男友吉尔。当他们分手后，他对仓库里的马特产生了兴趣。然后他最终与当时和安吉拉结婚的参议员发生了婚外情。州参议员。州参议员。然后奥斯卡宣布他有竞选州参议员的计划，但我们发现他最终去了托莱多一家小报社的会计部。
Nicely done, lady. I love a good show Bible. Yeah. A nice overview of the character. Well, Ant, I'm curious to hear what these Oscar personality traits are that fans love. Okay, well, this all started with a letter from Alexandra A in San Antonio, Texas. Alexandra said, Hi, office ladies, I have watched the office all the way through three times, and each time I find new things to love about Oscar. In my opinion, he is the best at throwing shade. My BFF thinks it's Phyllis or Angela, but I say no, it's Oscar. And I have a favorite, or at least a favorite, for right now.
干得漂亮，女士。我喜欢好的剧集圣经。是的。对角色的一个很好的概述。嗯，安特，我很好奇这些粉丝们喜欢的奥斯卡性格特点是什么。好吧，这一切始于德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥市亚历山德拉·A的一封信。亚历山德拉说：“嗨，办公室女士们，我已经把《办公室》完整看了三遍，每次我都能发现奥斯卡身上新的可爱之处。在我看来，他是最会讽刺人的。我闺蜜认为是菲利斯或安吉拉，但我说不，是奥斯卡。我有一个最喜欢的，或者至少是目前最喜欢的。”
I'm sure it will change, but it's when Ryan is getting arrested and goodbye Toby, and then Alexandra typed out her favorite quote, but I think Alexandra, let's hear Oscar do it rather than me read it because he's going to do it better. Well, this is what happened. Ryan's big project was the website, which wasn't doing so well. So Ryan, to give the impression of sales, recorded them twice, once his office sales and once his website sales, which is what we refer to the business as, misleading the shareholders. Another good term is fraud. The real crime I think was the beard. I love that. Alexandra goes on to say that gets me every time. Love you ladies, and I'm so excited for this episode. I mean, that's a pretty classic Oscar throwing shade. The beard. The beard. Yeah, that's pretty great. So Alexandra, you weren't alone and loving the Oscar shade, and this led me to dig into the other personality traits that people chat about online about the character of Oscar, there are two more that get a lot of chatter.
我相信它会改变，但那是瑞安在《再见托比》中被捕的时候，然后亚历山德拉打出了她最喜欢的台词，但我认为亚历山德拉，让我们听听奥斯卡自己说，而不是我读出来，因为他会说得更好。好吧，事情是这样的。瑞安的大项目是网站，但做得不太好。所以瑞安为了给人一种销售额很高的印象，把它们记录了两次，一次是办公室销售，一次是网站销售，这就是我们所说的商业行为，误导股东。另一个好词是欺诈。我认为真正的罪行是那把胡子。我喜欢那个。亚历山德拉接着说，那每次都让我笑喷。爱你们，女士们，我非常期待这一集。我的意思是，那是非常经典的奥斯卡式讽刺。那把胡子。那把胡子。是的，那太棒了。所以亚历山德拉，你并不孤单，很多人都喜欢奥斯卡的讽刺，这让我去挖掘了网上人们讨论的关于奥斯卡这个角色的其他性格特点，还有两个引起了很多讨论。
Okay. Okay. There is an overwhelming consensus online that he is also the voice of reason on the show. Oh, we talk with him about that. Yeah, right? Listen, Oscar Martinez, the character, he knows it. He even calls it out in this talking head. Let's hear it.
好的。好的。网上有一个压倒性的共识，那就是他也是剧中的理性之声。哦，我们和他聊过这个。是的，对吧？听着，奥斯卡·马丁内斯这个角色，他自己知道。他甚至在这次采访中提到了这一点。让我们听听。
All right. Who else is here? Pam and Jim are on their honeymoon. So there's not the usual balance between sane and others. Toby has mentally checked out since June. It's a very dangerous time. The coalition for reason is extremely weak. Sane versus others.
好了。还有谁在这儿？帕姆和吉姆去度蜜月了。所以没有了理智和其他人之间的通常平衡。托比从六月起就精神上离线了。这是一个非常危险的时刻。理性联盟极其薄弱。理智与其他人。
It really made me laugh. That's a combo. That's being the voice of reason and shade. Oh, you're right. You're right. That's a combo platter. Combo platter. Okay, the third personality trait that everyone online talks about
这真的让我笑了。那是一个组合。那是理性之声和讽刺的结合。哦，你说得对。你说得对。那是一个组合拼盘。组合拼盘。好的，网上每个人都在讨论的第三个性格特点
for the character Oscar is, he is the office know-it-all. Actually. Actually. And here's a fan-favorite moment where he corrects Meredith. Always with the friends, Oscar. Can't we just enjoy the new espresso machine? Actually, it's pronounced espresso. Wait, that's what you said.
关于奥斯卡这个角色是，他是办公室的“万事通”。其实。其实。这是一个粉丝最喜欢的时刻，他纠正了梅雷迪思。总是和朋友们在一起，奥斯卡。我们不能只是享受这台新的浓缩咖啡机吗？其实，它的发音是“浓缩咖啡”（espresso）。等等，那就是你说的。
I apologize. I just assumed you would mispronounce it. So I guess that's also know-it-all slash shade. Yes. Exactly. I think everything is slashed shade when it comes to Oscar. Well, listen, now it's time for us to share our favorite Oscar moments. Sam, do you want to go first? Sure. So I think Oscar plays drunk so well. It's my favorite thing he does in the show. We got so much mail about that. We talk with him about that. Yes. So all time in the ranking goes when him and Andy call Angela.
我道歉。我只是假设你会发错音。所以我猜那也是“万事通”加“讽刺”。是的。完全正确。我认为当涉及到奥斯卡时，一切都是“加讽刺”。好吧，听着，现在是我们分享我们最喜欢的奥斯卡时刻的时候了。山姆，你想先来吗？当然。所以我认为奥斯卡演醉酒演得太好了。这是他在剧中我最喜欢的事情。我们收到了很多关于那点的邮件。我们和他聊过那个。是的。所以排名第一的是他和安迪给安吉拉打电话的时候。
That's more of a visual gag. So this is a solid second for me. And I am Bacchus friend. It's his laugh before it. It's completely unhinged. Is that at the pool party? Yes, it is, yeah. I am Bacchus God of One. So good.
那更多是一个视觉笑话。所以这对我来说是稳居第二。我是巴克斯的朋友。那是他之前的笑声。完全失控了。那是在泳池派对上吗？是的，没错。我是巴克斯，酒神。太棒了。
Okay, Jenna, what about you? Well, I have a lot of favorite Oscar moments, but I love, for personal reasons as well, the Oscar Pam Angela Dynamic in the cold open for season eight after hours. Here is the clip. Hey, Angela. You want to see a picture?
好的，珍娜，你呢？嗯，我有很多最喜欢的奥斯卡时刻，但我出于个人原因，也非常喜欢第八季《下班后》开场中奥斯卡、帕姆和安吉拉的互动。这是片段。嘿，安吉拉。你想看一张照片吗？
of Philip wearing those little booties you got us? So cute. Hey, you guys want to see a picture of Gerald wearing galoshes? He refused to go out in the rain until I bought these. Now going out in the rain is all he wants to do. Oscar thinks having a dog is just like having a baby. Newsflash, if you didn't carry it around in your belly for nine months, it isn't your kid. Exactly.
菲利普穿着你给我们买的那些小靴子的照片？太可爱了。嘿，你们想看杰拉德穿着套鞋的照片吗？直到我买了这些，他才肯去雨中。现在去雨中是他唯一想做的事。奥斯卡认为养狗就像养孩子一样。新闻快讯，如果你没有在肚子里怀它九个月，它就不是你的孩子。完全正确。
Unless you adopted, of course. That is where we disagree. Hey, are your little dudes crawling yet? No. Three-month-old humans don't do that. My Philip is crawling. Angela is such a liar. It's maddening.
除非你领养了，当然。那就是我们意见不合的地方。嘿，你们的小家伙会爬了吗？没有。三个月大的人类不会那样。我的菲利普会爬了。安吉拉真是个骗子。太让人抓狂了。
Exactly. That's just like crate training. All night long, all night long. Well, count yourself lucky. Wait until you have two. That's two sleep schedules. Two naps that don't coincide. I mean, you'll never sleep again. No one said you must have two.
完全正确。那就像笼子训练一样。整晚，整晚。好吧，算你走运。等到你有两个的时候。那是两个睡眠时间表。两个不重合的小睡。我的意思是，你永远别想再睡觉了。没人说你必须有两个。
Like her genes are so important. The world just needs more Pam Jim DNA. Thank you, no. No. Thank you. Check this out. My brother just got a new sailboat. He has no idea what he just got himself into.
好像她的基因很重要。世界只需要更多的帕姆和吉姆的DNA。谢谢，不用了。不用了。谢谢。看看这个。我哥哥刚买了一艘新帆船。他根本不知道自己惹上了什么麻烦。
There's nothing harder than take care of a boat. Am I right? Unbelievable. Unbelievable. Unbelievable. So there it is. I just love how we were all teamed up. Oh yeah, and then being so catty.
没有什么比照顾船更难的了。我说得对吗？难以置信。难以置信。难以置信。所以就是这样。我只是喜欢我们所有人联合起来的样子。哦，是的，然后表现得那么刻薄。
I know. So it's like we're having this three-way conversation, but then we're pairing off to bitch about the other one. So much sidebar. Yes. Matt, it's your turn. I had to go with gay witch hunt. It's just the first thing that comes to mind.
我知道。所以就像我们在进行这种三人对话，但随后我们又两两分组去抱怨另一个人。太多的侧边对话了。是的。马特，轮到你了。我必须选《同性恋猎巫》。这是我脑海中浮现的第一件事。
And it's just these seven words that Oscar says. I'll let the clip speak for itself. I was going to quit. But Jan offered me a three-month paid vacation and a company car. All I had to do was sign something saying I won't sue. Gill and I are going to Europe. kids sometimes it pays to be gay it's so great
而且奥斯卡说的只有这七个字。我让片段自己说话。我本来打算辞职的。但简给了我三个月的带薪假期和一辆公司用车。我所要做的就是签一份声明，说我不会起诉。吉尔和我要去欧洲了。孩子们，有时候当同性恋是有好处的。太棒了。
I also just wanted to say that episode you both are so amazing Angela you're so mean to Oscar I know and Jenna your face when Michael is trying to kiss Oscar is just amazing you're both so great in that episode I rewatched that scene in the conference room earlier today and I fully saw
我还想说，那一集你们俩都太棒了，安吉拉，你对奥斯卡太刻薄了。我知道，还有珍娜，当迈克尔试图亲吻奥斯卡时，你的表情真是太棒了，你们在那一集中都太棒了。我今天早些时候重看了会议室里的那个场景，我完全看到了
Phyllis break. Oh, yeah. In the background. There's no hiding it. She fully breaks. Yeah. Yeah. All right, Angela, what about you? Okay. Well, I do love how many times Oscar gives people shade so much. I didn't pick any of them. I just have to go on record saying I love it. Anyway, just putting that out there. So the other thing I love is when people go to Oscar for advice. And we talked about that a little bit with him are when Oscar gives unsolicited advice. Amazing. So I went with this moment from Garage Sale in season seven. It's just the perfect little Oscar moment to me.
菲利斯笑场了。哦，是的。在背景里。没法隐藏。她完全笑场了。是的。是的。好吧，安吉拉，你呢？好的。嗯，我确实喜欢奥斯卡给别人讽刺的次数那么多。我一个都没选。我只是必须记录在案说我喜欢它。总之，只是提一下。所以我喜欢的另一件事是人们向奥斯卡寻求建议的时候。我们和他聊过一点，或者当奥斯卡给出未经请求的建议时。太棒了。所以我选了第七季《车库拍卖》中的这个时刻。对我来说，这只是完美的奥斯卡小瞬间。
And to jog your memory, Pam, Ryan and Jim and Oscar are all in the conference room with Michael, and they're going to help him figure out how to propose to Holly. Okay? And here's what Oscar says. So we want to help you plan the proposal so that it's safe and responsible and realistic and doable. I had a great idea until you ruined it. You want to know how to do it. Here's how you do it.
为了唤起你的记忆，帕姆、瑞安、吉姆和奥斯卡都在会议室里和迈克尔在一起，他们要帮他想出如何向霍莉求婚。好吗？这是奥斯卡说的。所以我们想帮你计划求婚，这样它既安全、负责、现实又可行。在你们毁掉它之前，我有一个好主意。你想知道怎么做吗？这就是怎么做。
Take her out to dinner, go down on one knee. If you are in costume, you did something wrong. If at any point you find yourself tying the ring to a dog's collar, stop and look at yourself. Like Pam's set up and then Oscar just jumping in and he knew he would try to be a character. Yes. And costume. No.
带她出去吃晚饭，单膝下跪。如果你穿着戏服，你就做错了。如果任何时候你发现自己在把戒指系在狗的项圈上，停下来看看你自己。就像帕姆的设定，然后奥斯卡跳出来，他知道他会试图成为一个角色。是的。还有戏服。不。
Well, listen, I don't want to wait any longer. I want you guys to hear this great conversation that we had with Oscar Nunez. So why don't we take a break and we will be back with Oscar in the studio. Yeah. G'day, I'm Justin Wolfers, host of the Platypus Economics podcast. If there's one thing I've learned from a career teaching economics, it's that your life is shaped by economic currents you'll never see. A single price tag can explain things a thousand experts can't.
好吧，听着，我不想再等了。我希望你们听听我们和奥斯卡·努涅斯进行的这次精彩对话。所以我们为什么不休息一下，然后我们会带着奥斯卡回到演播室。是的。你好，我是贾斯汀·沃尔弗斯，《鸭嘴兽经济学》播客的主持人。如果说我在教授经济学的职业生涯中学到了什么，那就是你的生活是由你永远看不见的经济潮流塑造的。一个单一的价格标签可以解释一千个专家无法解释的事情。
People who understand economics, they make better decisions in their careers, their finances, their relationships and their communities, and I want that for you. Listen to and follow Platypus Economics, available now wherever you get your podcasts. Oscar, thank you so much for joining us on the Office Ladies Podcasts here in studio. My pleasure. Here I am. I don't know. Listeners, we're not being filmed. These ladies are in an old-timey, traditional, beautiful building on the corner, high up. I was in the elevator with Angela coming up and she goes, you know what? Clark Gable played poker in the basement. What? That's where we are. Carry on. This man told me. There's an older gentleman on the fifth
了解经济学的人，他们在职业生涯、财务、人际关系和社区中会做出更好的决定，我希望你也能这样。收听并关注《鸭嘴兽经济学》，现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听。奥斯卡，非常感谢你来到我们《办公室女士》播客的演播室。我的荣幸。我在这儿。我不知道。听众们，我们没有被拍摄。这些女士们在一个位于拐角处、高高在上的老式、传统、美丽的建筑里。我和安吉拉上楼时在电梯里，她说，你知道吗？克拉克·盖博曾在地下室打扑克。什么？我们就在那儿。继续。这个人告诉我的。五楼有一位年长的绅士
floor who was telling me some history. This is very apropos. So surreal. And we're here and we are going to talk to you all about your character, Oscar Martinez. You know, the name of this episode is all about Oscar. No, I think I knew that. Okay. He did because we talked to them well. I told you. But first, we wanted to congratulate you on the success of the paper and on season two, which is coming out today. Okay, yes, thank you. Wow. This airs as the day. Season two is premiering on Peacock. Very exciting.
正在告诉我一些历史。这非常贴切。太超现实了。我们在这儿，我们要和你聊聊你的角色，奥斯卡·马丁内斯。你知道，这一集的标题是“关于奥斯卡”。不，我想我知道。好的。他知道，因为我们和他们聊过。我告诉过你。但首先，我们要祝贺你在《纸》中取得的成功，以及今天播出的第二季。好的，是的，谢谢。哇。这集播出的时候就是这一天。第二季正在Peacock首播。非常令人兴奋。
And then for season one, you were nominated for a Critics Choice Award. You personally. Yeah. Thank you. Oscar. I appreciate that. I appreciate that. Yes.
然后第一季，你获得了评论家选择奖提名。你个人。是的。谢谢。奥斯卡。我很感激。我很感激。是的。
What has it been like to take this character from one series to another? You know what, Jenna? It's been seamless. It's been seamless. Because as all the characters, it's a solid character. We're all so well-developed the characters, every one of them. Yeah. So it's been seamless.
把这个角色从一个系列带到另一个系列是什么感觉？你知道吗，珍娜？它是无缝衔接的。它是无缝衔接的。因为就像所有的角色一样，这是一个扎实的角色。我们所有人都被塑造得很好，每一个角色。是的。所以它是无缝衔接的。
And I love playing the straight man. I mean, he's a gay guy, but he plays a straight guy, right? Yeah. And I love that. I love reacting to things. I mean, don't get me wrong. If they're like, Oscar, anyone on the office, I'm like, either Dwight or Steve, of course. But to play a straight person off these people is so.
而且我喜欢扮演直男。我的意思是，他是个同性恋，但他扮演一个直男，对吧？是的。我喜欢那样。我喜欢对事情做出反应。我的意思是，别误会我。如果他们问，奥斯卡，《办公室》里的任何人，我会说，要么是德怀特要么是史蒂夫，当然。但扮演一个直人来衬托这些人真是太……
So fun. Mm-hmm. And I get to keep doing it now. So I get to keep, you know, and it's a whole crop of new people. I have friends and they're new, you know, Donal, who is so talented. So talented. Who works with Steve. Yeah.
太有趣了。嗯哼。我现在可以继续做这件事了。所以我可以继续，你知道，这是一群新人。我有朋友，他们是新的，你知道，唐纳，他太有才华了。太有才华了。他和史蒂夫一起工作。是的。
And Donald's in everything. Everything. He's like Emily Blount. He's in everything, this kid. And Alex Edelman, my new favorite stand-up. He's so funny. Jenna. Is he cracking you up on set?
而且唐纳什么都演。什么都演。他就像艾米莉·布朗特。他什么都演，这孩子。还有亚历克斯·埃德尔曼，我最喜欢的新单口喜剧演员。他太搞笑了。珍娜。他在片场让你笑了吗？
Is he the fun? one on set? He's very funny on set, but he's very smart, and he's a writer. So he's not joking around all the time. Right. But he's super smart. I mean, crazy. I'm so in love with him.
他是片场那个有趣的人吗？他在片场非常有趣，但他非常聪明，他是个编剧。所以他不是一直都在开玩笑。对。但他超级聪明。我的意思是，疯狂。我太爱他了。
Ursus, like, he's like your nephew. I'm like, you're right. I can't say enough about Alex. And we've gone to see him after, like, just for us, he did a show at the Ford, and he went and he did it with Ben Harper because he's a fan. And so they did a show together. He's more comfortable on stage than he is in Alex in real life. He's so good on stage and so funny.
厄苏斯，就像，他就像你的侄子。我说，你说得对。我怎么夸亚历克斯都不为过。我们去看过他之后，就像，只是为了我们，他在福特剧院做了一场演出，他和本·哈珀一起做了，因为他是粉丝。所以他们一起做了一场演出。他在舞台上比在现实生活中更自在。他在舞台上太棒了，太搞笑了。
I can't say enough about him. Anyway, Alex, Chelsea is a new friend. Chelsea is so delightful. She's been in the studio here and chatted with us. And we just love her. Adore her. Yeah, she's very cool. Adore her.
我怎么夸他都不为过。总之，亚历克斯，切尔西是个新朋友。切尔西太可爱了。她来过演播室和我们聊天。我们非常喜欢她。崇拜她。是的，她很酷。崇拜她。
So you know what? Well, it's, you know, look, they all went through the Greg Daniels filter. They're all nice people. There's no bad, you know. That's right. So those are my new friends and more, but those are the ones that come to mind the most. And Bemi. And yeah, they're all.
所以你知道吗？好吧，这是，你知道，看，他们都经过了格雷格·丹尼尔斯的筛选。他们都是好人。没有坏的，你知道。那是对的。所以那些是我的新朋友，还有更多，但那些是我最先想到的。还有贝米。是的，他们都是。
I mean, yeah. I realize Jenna and I are now becoming the people that when people would interview us, like, who's the prankster? Who's the jokes? Oh my gosh. We're asking all the questions now that people used to ask that. That's crazy. It's kind of crazy. I know.
我的意思是，是的。我意识到珍娜和我现在变成了那种当人们采访我们时，就像，谁是恶作剧者？谁是笑话担当？天哪。我们现在在问所有人们过去问我们的问题。那太疯狂了。这有点疯狂。我知道。
Okay, we want to ask you questions about Oscar. Yeah. We have some and fans wrote in really fun. I don't know the answers. We don't know all of these answers. And also the fans wrote in Oscar. And they're so thoughtful and they love your character. So we're excited to dive in.
好的，我们想问你关于奥斯卡的问题。是的。我们有一些，粉丝们写进来的非常有趣。我不知道答案。我们不知道所有这些答案。而且粉丝们写给奥斯卡的信。他们非常体贴，他们喜欢你的角色。所以我们很兴奋能深入探讨。
This first question, I did not know the answer to. Okay. Okay. So we know that aspects of Oscar's character, like all of our characters, got revealed over time, that the writers would write to us over time. And like you said, fully flesh us out. Yes, ma'am. But early on, in those early days, when we didn't have all of that to work with, did you create any backstory for the character of Oscar? Like where he was from, his family, anything like that, how he ended up at Dunder Mifflin. No, what happened the way I approached it or whatever. I got the job because of improv because it was a good day for auditions for me. On that day, I had four auditions. So the time I got to the office, I just didn't care.
第一个问题，我不知道答案。好的。好的。所以我们知道奥斯卡角色的各个方面，就像我们所有的角色一样，是随着时间推移而揭示的，编剧们会随着时间推移为我们写作。就像你说的，完全充实我们。是的，女士。但在早期，在那些日子里，当我们没有那么多东西可以利用时，你为奥斯卡这个角色创造过任何背景故事吗？比如他来自哪里，他的家庭，诸如此类的，他是怎么进入邓德·米夫林的。不，发生的事情是我接近它的方式或者其他什么。我得到这份工作是因为即兴表演，因为那天对我来说是试镜的好日子。那天，我有四次试镜。所以当我到达办公室时，我根本不在乎。
And that's the best way to go in. You were super loose. It was your fourth audition in one day. Yeah. So it was a good actor's day. I'm like, I felt like an actor that day. Because you could go a week and not have one. You're like, what am I doing?
那是最好的进入方式。你超级放松。那是你一天中的第四次试镜。是的。所以那是演员的好日子。我感觉那天我像个演员。因为你可能一周都没有一次。你会想，我在做什么？
So it was a good day. And then you go back more. And it's improv and that's what we do. And I don't know why, but in my mind, I was like the boss of our clump of Kevin, Angela, myself. Because of where I was seated. And I thought. But then as we started improvising and going, Angela kind of began. And I'm like, oh.
所以那是美好的一天。然后你回去更多。这是即兴表演，这就是我们所做的。我不知道为什么，但在我脑海里，我是我们这群人——凯文、安吉拉、我自己——的老大。因为我坐的位置。我以为。但当我们开始即兴表演时，安吉拉开始……我心想，哦。
And so I was thinking about that. And I was like, okay, now I have to, I'm going to adjust a little bit, you know? Yeah. Because now she's at. I'm like, okay, so now we're like the parents of Kevin. That happened pretty like organically because. We started improvising over there in the clump, and I just sort of took high status because I was so prim and proper. And then you were just instantly annoyed with me.
所以我当时在想那个。我心想，好吧，现在我必须，我要稍微调整一下，你知道？是的。因为现在她在……我心想，好吧，所以现在我们就像凯文的父母。那发生得相当有机，因为……我们在那群人里开始即兴表演，我只是因为我太一本正经而占据了高位。然后你立刻就被我惹恼了。
It was perfect. It was organic. And you did it. And you snapped at me because you demanded, because you're like, you're talking to him. What happened? What did he say? And I'm like, you saw me. And then that was it.
太完美了。它是自然的。你做到了。你对我发火，因为你要求，因为你就像，你在和他说话。发生了什么？他说了什么？我心想，你看见我了。然后就是那样。
That was it. And the writers were like, what? They're really good improvisers. We're like, yeah, that's what we do. And then they started writing a little bit more for us. Yeah. And Kevin said, were you guys talking about? You're like, nothing or shut up.
就是那样。编剧们心想，什么？他们真是很好的即兴表演者。我们心想，是的，这就是我们做的。然后他们开始为我们写更多一点。是的。凯文说，你们在聊什么？你就像，没什么，或者闭嘴。
You just shut him down. I said nothing and you said almost the same thing at the same time. I go nothing and you went, eh. Yeah, like, don't worry about it. Like, what's, like, and he came in with that sweet, like, and the speed, he's like, where do you guys talk? And you're like, shh, no. Yeah. Well, I'm curious right now, who was the head accountant of that club?
你只是让他闭嘴。我说没什么，你几乎在同一时间说了同样的话。我说没什么，你说了“呃”。是的，就像，别担心。就像，什么，就像，他带着那种甜甜的，就像，速度，他就像，你们在聊什么？你就像，嘘，不。是的。好吧，我现在很好奇，那群人的首席会计师是谁？
I don't think they had one. We did. We figured it out ourselves. But I mean, who would you say? Do you think it was me? And she just started. You think it was you, Angela? I think I had to schedule everything, and I had to make sure everything got done.
我不认为他们有一个。我们有。我们自己弄清楚了。但我的意思是，你会说是谁？你觉得是我吗？然后她就开始了。你觉得是你吗，安吉拉？我想我必须安排一切，我必须确保一切都完成。
And I feel like some of the invisible labor came down to Angela Martin. Oh, my God, I love this. I love this. So Oscar had the job, and you're like, but I am doing all the work. But I get everything done. But who does Michael go to? Oscar. But who turned in the paperwork?
我觉得一些隐形劳动落在了安吉拉·马丁身上。天哪，我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。所以奥斯卡有这份工作，你就像，但我做了所有的工作。但我把一切都做完了。但迈克尔去找谁？奥斯卡。但谁提交了文书工作？
Me. It works perfectly. Delicious. Because he's a misogynist, and he feels good that he's going to a lot. That makes him feel good. Look what I'm doing. Michael. Yes, as the character.
我。它运作得非常完美。美味。因为他是个厌女症患者，他觉得他去找一个男人感觉很好。这让他感觉很好。看看我在做什么。迈克尔。是的，作为角色。
He's like... Which would make Angela be resentful of Oscar, right? That she's doing some work. Yeah, just another thing to be resent. But another thing of like, welcome to my world. Yes. Hello, ladies. We all, this is what women know this is...
他就像……这会让安吉拉对奥斯卡产生怨恨，对吧？她做了一些工作。是的，只是另一件值得怨恨的事情。但另一件就像，欢迎来到我的世界。是的。你好，女士们。我们都，这是女性知道这是……
I guess this is what I have to do. This is the workplace. Well, I have a question for you. And a few fans wrote in with a... similar question. They want to know if I answered the last one. You did. I think you did. I think you said in your mind, Oscar was in charge. Yeah, but in other words, I was in the moment. I wasn't like backstory, parents, none of that. I'm like, we're here. Like, we did the pilot. And then that second script came in. And I've said this before. And I'm like, who wrote this? Diversity day.
我想这就是我必须做的。这就是工作场所。好吧，我有一个问题要问你。一些粉丝写信问了一个……类似的问题。他们想知道我是否回答了上一个。你回答了。我想你回答了。我想你说在你脑海里，奥斯卡是负责的。是的，但换句话说，我当时在状态中。我没有背景故事，父母，那些都没有。我心想，我们在这儿。就像，我们拍了试播集。然后第二个剧本进来了。我以前说过。我心想，谁写的这个？多元化日。
Yeah. And they're like, that kidding. I'm like, the kid writing the skateboard, that teenager, the sullen kid from Harvard. I'm like, oh, we're in good hands. Because this. script wasn't good. It was really, really good. That was a killer script. I'm like, oh, my God, this show. Yeah. This is good.
是的。他们就像，那孩子。我心想，那个骑滑板的孩子，那个青少年，那个来自哈佛的阴郁的孩子。我心想，哦，我们有救了。因为这个剧本不只是好。它真的、真的很好。那是一个杀手级剧本。我心想，天哪，这部剧。是的。这很好。
We didn't want to jinx it, but I'm like, oh, this is going to be good. Yeah. Anyway. Oh, no, I think we all felt that way. It felt like, you know, lightning in a bottle. That was a really good. And then the script was good, but then we were having fun because Mindy couldn't get through the scene when she's like, he's like, he's like, uh, put you, muly, muly,
我们不想触霉头，但我心想，哦，这会很棒。是的。总之。哦，不，我想我们都有那种感觉。感觉就像，你知道，瓶子里的闪电。那真的很好。然后剧本很好，但我们玩得很开心，因为明迪在演那场戏时无法坚持下去，当她就像，他就像，他就像，呃，普吉，穆利，穆利，
and she slaps it, but she's not, she didn't act as much as we did this, so she's just laughing. And we're like, what's happening? Take 27 and she's like, I can't. And how could she not when he's in her face? Mugibu Kyi. I know. I know.
然后她打了它，但她没有像我们那样演，所以她只是在笑。我们心想，发生了什么？第27次拍摄，她就像，我做不到。当他在她面前时，她怎么能不笑呢？穆吉布·基。我知道。我知道。
Okay, wait. So a bunch of people wrote in with the same question, which is, did you have a favorite Oscar storyline? Like if there. Storyline? Yeah, if you look back on like those nine seasons. I know it's a really tough question. No, no, it's not a tough question because the other day or six months ago, I don't even know anymore. I was watching the episode.
好的，等等。所以很多人写信问了同一个问题，那就是，你有一个最喜欢的奥斯卡故事情节吗？就像如果那里有。故事情节？是的，如果你回顾那九季。我知道这是一个非常棘手的问题。不，不，这不是一个棘手的问题，因为前几天或者六个月前，我甚至不知道了。我正在看那一集。
you're like, Oscar, and I have the draw open and I'm leaning on it. And you're like, I think the senator is having an affair on the floor. Yeah. And you dropped the drawer and catch it. And then that scene is so good, Angela. It's so fun. Because at the beginning, I don't know. I'm like, Blake.
你就像，奥斯卡，我把抽屉打开，我靠在上面。你就像，我想参议员在楼层有外遇。是的。你把抽屉扔掉并接住它。然后那场戏太棒了，安吉拉。太有趣了。因为一开始，我不知道。我就像，布莱克。
Who's Blake? Yeah, who's Blake? Yeah, like, who's, what's with the yoga? I know, the yoga. And then I'm like, no, relax. And then you're like, we need to go. And I'm like, no, I don't want to go. No, we need to check it out.
谁是布莱克？是的，谁是布莱克？是的，就像，瑜伽是怎么回事？我知道，瑜伽。然后我就像，不，放松。然后你就像，我们需要走。我就像，不，我不想走。不，我们需要去看看。
First she was worried. And then I'm the one thing. She's like, okay, whatever. It's brilliant. I love that. It's so messed up. And then we go to the thing and we're spying on them and the stupid telephone. And your phone rings.
起初她很担心。然后我是那件事。她就像，好吧，随便吧。太精彩了。我喜欢那个。太乱了。然后我们去那儿，我们监视他们，还有那部愚蠢的电话。你的电话响了。
It's the stupidest joke in the world. Yeah. Terrible. Well, we got a lot of mail about that storyline. That's the writers, man. Those are the writers. If we can't make that funny, there's something wrong with us because it's all there. People were really curious how you felt, I mean, we know that it was very funny, but they were
那是世界上最愚蠢的笑话。是的。糟糕。好吧，我们收到了很多关于那个故事情节的邮件。那是编剧，伙计。那是编剧。如果我们不能让它变得有趣，那我们就有问题了，因为它就在那儿。人们真的很好奇你的感受，我的意思是，我们知道它非常有趣，但他们
like, were you surprised to see that Oscar Martinez would go behind Angela Martin's back like that? It's horrible. No one would do that. But it's a TV show. It's not real. So we stretch and we pull and we push the boundaries. It was horrible.
就像，你惊讶地看到奥斯卡·马丁内斯会那样背着安吉拉·马丁吗？太可怕了。没人会那样做。但这是一部电视剧。这不是真的。所以我们伸展，我们拉扯，我们推动界限。这太可怕了。
Who would do that? And then he's fine with it. I like Angela, but she can't keep her man. You know, it's just, but then I come back and I'm like, hey, stay with me, you know? Yeah. So it's a lot going on. Yeah. I was watching the scenes this morning where, wait, were they the ones at the fundraiser?
谁会那样做？然后他对此没问题。我喜欢安吉拉，但她留不住她的男人。你知道，这只是，但后来我回来，我就像，嘿，留在我身边，你知道？是的。所以发生了很多事。是的。我今天早上在看那些场景，等等，是筹款活动上的那些吗？
Yes. The fundraiser. Oscar, when you're just like, he's hitting. on me and then the journey that you go on. And then they're like, he gave me his card. The fundraiser. Jim's like, I think he gives everyone their card. Yeah.
是的。筹款活动。奥斯卡，当你就像，他在勾引我，然后你经历的旅程。然后他们就像，他给了我他的名片。筹款活动。吉姆就像，我想他给了每个人他的名片。是的。
And then at the end when he slides his hand down Oscar's sleeve, and then my favorite is you like to give him, why does this keep happening to me? That's good. And then you're like, oh, I feel so bad for Angela. I could not be happier. I could not be happier. I know. I could not be happier.
然后在最后，当他把手滑下奥斯卡的袖子时，然后我最喜欢的是你喜欢给他，为什么这种事一直发生在我身上？那很好。然后你就像，哦，我为安吉拉感到难过。我不能更开心了。我不能更开心了。我知道。我不能更开心了。
And remember, here comes the wise one who we think doesn't know what's going on. And he defend us, Kevin, on the porch. He goes, these are two good people. And you suck, basically, right? There was a scene who were leaving. And you and I are that like, we're just like hand towels that you can use. Yeah. And he's like, yeah, you kind of suck.
记住，那个我们认为不知道发生了什么的智者来了。他在门廊上为我们辩护，凯文。他走过去，这些人是两个好人。你基本上很烂，对吧？有一个场景我们要离开。你和我就像你可以使用的手巾。是的。他就像，是的，你有点烂。
You suck. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's really cool. Great party. You suck. We have a follow-up fan question from Stephanie C. in Powder Springs, Georgia, who would like to know after all of this has happened and the Angela and Oscar. storyline, do you think Oscar still keeps in touch with her?
你烂透了。是的，是的，是的。太酷了。很棒的派对。你烂透了。我们有一个来自佐治亚州粉泉市斯蒂芬妮·C的后续粉丝问题，她想知道在所有这些事情发生之后，安吉拉和奥斯卡的故事情节，你认为奥斯卡还和她保持联系吗？
In the show? In the post-Dundermifflin world. Stephanie gives an example. She said, for example, would Oscar, even if it's just a Christmas card every year, do you think Angela and him exchange some kind of thing? Well, no, they do stay in touch because remember, who's the godfather of the kid? Oscar. Philip, yes.
在剧中？在邓德·米夫林后的世界。斯蒂芬妮给了一个例子。她说，例如，奥斯卡会，即使只是每年一张圣诞卡，你认为安吉拉和他交换某种东西吗？嗯，不，他们确实保持联系，因为记住，谁是孩子的教父？奥斯卡。菲利普，是的。
Rain reminded me that on his podcast. Someone asked the same question. I'm like, why would Ray? Huck, and then Rain's like, oh, wait, aren't you? And I'm like, oh, snap, sorry. And I had to apologize to the person who asked a question. I'm like, it wasn't a ridiculous question. I'm the godfather of their kid.
雷恩在播客上提醒了我。有人问了同样的问题。我心想，为什么雷恩会？哈克，然后雷恩就像，哦，等等，你不是吗？我心想，哦，糟糕，抱歉。我不得不向问问题的人道歉。我心想，这不是一个荒谬的问题。我是他们孩子的教父。
Yeah. So, yeah. You have to show up sometime for something, some birthday or something. And also, Philip meant a lot to Oscar. If you look back on the finale, Oscar's holding Philip at the wedding. And then one of my favorite things is- And so did Angela. I think they do like staying in touch a little bit.
是的。所以，是的。你必须在某个时候为某事出现，某个生日或其他什么。而且菲利普对奥斯卡意义重大。如果你回顾大结局，奥斯卡在婚礼上抱着菲利普。然后我最喜欢的事情之一是——安吉拉也是。我想他们确实喜欢保持一点联系。
Absolutely. I loved it when Angela's laying out Philip's outfit for the day and Oscar comes in and goes, No, the best. Those shoes, are you kidding me? No, not over my dead body. Like a little baby shoes and like trades them out. Angela, I will call child protective. Child protective
绝对。我喜欢安吉拉为菲利普布置当天的衣服，奥斯卡走进来，说，不，最好的。那些鞋子，你在开玩笑吗？不，除非我死了。就像小婴儿鞋，然后把它们换掉。安吉拉，我会打电话给儿童保护。儿童保护
services. The best line. Saddles denim and saddle shoes and it was a talking hat, I will call child protective. That's right. That's a good line. Yeah. Okay, we have some more fan questions for you. These are good questions. All right. So folks are very aware that you almost
服务。最好的台词。马鞍牛仔布和马鞍鞋，那是一个谈话帽，我会打电话给儿童保护。那是对的。那是一句好台词。是的。好的，我们还有更多粉丝问题要问你。这些是好问题。好吧。所以大家非常清楚你几乎
never broke on the show. And there are actually a few Instagram accounts that feature the very few times that you did laugh. They're super funny. But we were curious, do you have a moment that you remember that was the hardest you ever laughed on set? Like something that really got you. Even if you didn't break in the scene. Oh, even if I didn't break in the scene? Yes.
从不在剧中笑场。实际上有几个Instagram账号专门展示你那几次笑场的时刻。它们超级有趣。但我们很好奇，你记得你在片场笑得最厉害的时刻吗？就像真正让你笑喷的东西。即使你没有在场景中笑场。哦，即使我没有在场景中笑场？是的。
Just like, what do you look back on? Like the minute they yelled cut and you were just like, oh. Well, the Santa Claus. Oh, yes. Little boy, sits on my, and oh, God. You know. The one where Ed had to dive behind the wall because he was laughing. We couldn't get through it.
就像，你回顾什么？就像他们喊“卡”的那一分钟，你就像，哦。嗯，圣诞老人。哦，是的。小男孩，坐在我身上，天哪。你知道。埃德不得不躲在墙后，因为他在笑。我们无法完成它。
And the things they would say is like, he's like, little boy, what do you want? And he's like, I don't know. And he's like, what, do you think of it? And then you think of it before you sat down and no one's ever asked me to sit on their lap before, oh, God, what do you? You know, and he's just thinking about it. What's he going to get? But he asked for it. Little boy sit on my lap.
他们会说的事情就像，他就像，小男孩，你想要什么？他就像，我不知道。他就像，什么，你觉得它怎么样？然后你在坐下之前想一想，从来没有人要求我坐在他们腿上，哦，天哪，你想要什么？你知道，他只是在想它。他要得到什么？但他要求了。小男孩坐在我腿上。
And then one of the scenes that they couldn't use is he gets up and his legs asleep and he starts banging it. And that's when Krasinski is just like at his mercy sitting there. Yeah. But as far as cracking up, I think Steve cracked me a few times. But Ed Helms, what I think cracked me up most consistently. Oh, yeah? With his mugs, his faces he would do. I thought we're so good and so funny.
然后他们不能用的场景之一是他站起来，他的腿麻了，他开始敲打它。那就是克拉辛斯基只是坐在那里任他摆布的时候。是的。但至于笑喷，我想史蒂夫让我笑了几次。但埃德·赫尔姆斯，我认为最让我笑得最厉害。哦，是吗？用他的马克杯，他会做的表情。我觉得我们太棒了，太搞笑了。
I said this before. The Andy Griffith show is an old TV show. Yeah. In black and white. And in the town of Mayberry, there's a barbershop. It's Floyd's Barbershop. And that character, you guys are too young, you're looking at me like, there's Floyd the Barber, and that character reminds me of Andy.
我以前说过。安迪·格里菲斯秀是一个老电视节目。是的。黑白的。在梅伯里镇，有一家理发店。那是弗洛伊德理发店。那个角色，你们太年轻了，你们看着我，就像，有弗洛伊德理发师，那个角色让我想起了安迪。
I don't know why. I want to go back and find, I mean, you know, those episodes are out there. My grandparents watch that show. You were supposed to my grandparents. Her grandparents watched it, Oscar. Did you watch it with her grandparents? No, no, no, come on. I have to look at my wife.
我不知道为什么。我想回去找，我是说，你知道，那些剧集都在那儿。我祖父母看那个节目。你本该是我祖父母的。她祖父母看了，奥斯卡。你和她祖父母一起看了吗？不，不，不，得了吧。我得看看我妻子。
I have to leave. Oh, no. My grandparents. No, no, I'm not. My great grandparents watched it. Oh, Jenna. I believe it. Most people who watched that, I think, have died.
我得走了。噢，不。我祖父母。不，不，我没有。我曾祖父母看了。噢，珍娜。我相信。我想大多数看那个节目的人都已经去世了。
Most people. Because they're so, so old. I was really young. My only defense is I was really young when I watched it. You were three years old. Not really. I wasn't that young. Well, I do remember it, like, when I would go visit them in the summer, like, they would have it on.
大多数人。因为他们太老了。我当时真的很年轻。我唯一的辩解就是我看那个节目的时候真的很年轻。你当时三岁。不完全是。我没那么小。嗯，我确实记得，比如，夏天我去探望他们的时候，他们会放那个节目。
And I remember the beginning because he whistled, right? Ron Howard is the little boy with the fish of old. Yeah. Yeah. We know it. Yeah. Okay. But I can't remember Floyd.
我记得开头，因为他吹口哨了，对吧？朗·霍华德是那个带着旧鱼的小男孩。对。对。我们知道。对。好吧。但我记不起弗洛伊德了。
I want to go find him. But yeah, Ed gave really good face. Really good face. And he was well written. It was a very extreme, funny, funny, funny character. But see, I didn't know that till today, that the character that consistently made you break was Andy. And he would get away with doing things that Michael would.
我想去找他。但确实，埃德的表情非常到位。非常到位。而且剧本写得很好。那是一个非常极端、有趣、有趣、有趣的角色。但你看，我直到今天才知道，那个一直让你笑场的角色是安迪。他总能逃脱惩罚，做迈克尔会做的事。
He was a very extreme character, but anchored. And he was like, what is happening? And he did something. He's like thinking of something. He went like this to think. And I'm like, who did? Oh, I remember. I went like this and I couldn't.
他是一个非常极端的角色，但很稳重。他就像是，发生了什么事？他做了些什么。他好像在想什么。他做了这个动作来思考。我心想，谁做的？噢，我记得。我做了这个动作，我没法……
Put his like fingers to his mouth. Yeah, like a steeple. And I'm like, no, I can't. And I started laughing. Mm-hmm. And then I remember he got her step up as a cat. And he went prowling around John Crizzynskin. He's like, who am I?
把手指放在嘴边。对，像个尖塔。我心想，不，我做不到。然后我开始笑。嗯哼。然后我记得他让她像猫一样站起来。他开始在约翰·克拉辛斯基周围徘徊。他心想，我是谁？
And John's like, oh, my God. I was watching the scene too where, you know, a lot of people go to Oscar for advice. It's kind of interesting. If you rewatch the office, Oscars who a lot of people go to. Because there's no one else. Everyone who else is. I know. I know.
约翰心想，噢，天哪。我也在看那一幕，你知道，很多人去找奥斯卡寻求建议。这挺有趣的。如果你重看《办公室》，奥斯卡是很多人去找的人。因为没有别人了。其他所有人都是。我知道。我知道。
Because he's the voice of reason. Jenna was smart and reasonable, but Jenna was in love. And she was in love. I didn't have time to give me. Pam. Or the inclination. You're like a nice person. I would tell it to them like it is.
因为他是理性的声音。珍娜很聪明也很理智，但珍娜恋爱了。她恋爱了。我没时间给我。帕姆。或者没那个倾向。你是个好人。我会直接告诉他们真相。
You know what? I think that Pam, I'm not sure people wanted her advice because she seemed a little bit like she was a grounded person. But I don't think she had her shit together, right? Like she was engaged and then she's with this other guy. Is she going to our school? A little bit of a blade of grass blowing in the. window a little bit, a little bit. But Oscar was pretty anchored.
你知道吗？我觉得帕姆，我不确定人们是否想要她的建议，因为她看起来有点像个脚踏实地的人。但我不觉得她把自己的生活打理得井井有条，对吧？比如她订婚了，然后又和这个男人在一起。她要去我们学校吗？有点像窗边随风飘荡的草叶，一点点，一点点。但奥斯卡相当稳重。
Much more stable of a person. But, no, I was watching the scene where Andy goes to Oscar. No, it's a vest. And it's like, let's say Brad Pitt gets on me. And then my talking is, it can't be my place. Surely this can't be part of my, like, work description or something that I have to. Like, you have to, like, secure him, like, make him securing his. Like, yeah.
是一个更稳定的人。但是，不，我当时在看安迪去找奥斯卡的那一幕。不，那是件背心。就像是，假设布拉德·皮特穿在我身上。然后我的台词是，这不可能是我的位置。这肯定不是我的工作职责的一部分，或者我必须……就像，你必须，比如，固定住他，让他固定在他的。就像，对。
That was a funny episode. and that's, again, Ed Helms. Yeah. Is there a character you wish Oscar had more scenes with? Is it Andy? Oh, that's a good one, probably. I always say Steve, because he was so good and it was so fun.
那是一集很有趣的剧。而且，再说一次，那是埃德·赫尔姆斯。对。有没有哪个角色你希望奥斯卡能有更多对手戏？是安迪吗？噢，那是个好问题，大概吧。我总是说是史蒂夫，因为他太棒了，而且非常有趣。
And I had some scenes with him. Oscar and Michael had a lot of great moments. We had a lot of great moments. A highlight is from the surplus when you have to explain what a surplus is to end. Oh, my goodness. The lemonade stand. I don't know how you kept a straight face Oscar,
我和他有一些对手戏。奥斯卡和迈克尔有很多精彩的时刻。我们有很多精彩的时刻。一个亮点是来自盈余那一集，你必须向安迪解释什么是盈余。噢，天哪。柠檬水摊。我不知道你是怎么忍住不笑的，奥斯卡。
because, you know, as your character, you're laying it out like the math of it. And then you're like in the next year, and Steve is my call goes, I'll be six. Like he's missing the point altogether. But he's on it. He answered quickly. He's on it.
因为，你知道，作为你的角色，你像是在列出数学计算。然后你在下一年，史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔说，我会是六岁。就像他完全没抓住重点。但他反应很快。他反应很快。
And it's, you know, it just struck me too that Oscar gets advice and all that. But when push comes to shove, he's such a know-at-all. But sometimes he gets putting a position where he fumbles the ball, which is very human. Mm-hmm. You know, like I was in a. room with like men or something CEOs. We might have gone on a trip to three of us, Andy, and I got a chance to like speak your mind and I fumbled it.
而且，你知道，这也让我印象深刻，奥斯卡会提供建议等等。但当关键时刻来临时，他是个十足的万事通。但有时他会被置于一个搞砸局面的境地，这非常人性化。嗯哼。你知道，就像我在一个房间里，和男人们或者首席执行官们在一起。我们可能一起去旅行了，我们三个，安迪，我有机会表达我的想法，但我搞砸了。
And I was, you know, which happens. A shareholder meeting. Yes. Which is very funny. Yeah. Yeah. Well, speaking of the surplus, that is one of my personal favorite Pam Oscar storylines. Right.
而且我当时，你知道，这确实发生了。股东大会。是的。这非常有趣。对。对。嗯，说到盈余，那是我个人最喜欢的帕姆和奥斯卡的故事情节之一。对。
And I love it because often we were allies because we were the reasonable people in the office. That's right. Now here we were like adversarial. Because you wanted the chair? What did you want? You wanted the chair. You wanted copier. So I'm asking you now, Jenna to Oscar Nunez in real life, would you choose new chairs or a new copier?
我喜欢它，因为我们经常是盟友，因为我们是办公室里理智的人。没错。现在我们在这里像是对手。因为你想要那把椅子？你想要什么？你想要椅子。你想要复印机。所以我现在问你，珍娜，问现实生活中的奥斯卡·努涅斯，你会选择新椅子还是新复印机？
Oh, Martinez says copier. Nunez, I think says chairs. Thank you. Chairs. We all know it's chairs. Yeah. I feel as passionate about chairs as Jenna as I did as Pam. Okay.
噢，马丁内斯说复印机。努涅斯，我想说是椅子。谢谢。椅子。我们都知道是椅子。对。我像珍娜作为帕姆时一样，对椅子充满热情。好的。
I think it's chairs. Let me say, I've had real jobs and I wasn't a good worker because I would pick chairs over a copier. Martinez, the pragmatic thing would have been copiers. But here, I'm with you, chairs. Have you guys ever had to make a lot of copies? Yes. I did. I worked in a mail room and like having a shittie copier is a huge time suck on your day and extra work.
我觉得是椅子。让我说，我做过真正的工作，我不是个好员工，因为我会选椅子而不是复印机。马丁内斯，务实的做法应该是复印机。但在这里，我站在你这边，椅子。你们有没有过必须复印大量文件的时候？有。我做过。我在收发室工作，有一个烂复印机简直是浪费时间，而且是额外的工作。
Yes, I had to collate giant things using a copier. Yes. I still pick chairs. There would be paper jams. You have to open the whole thing up. But in Jenna's defense, am I imagining things? Jenna spent a lot of time in her chair because she's the receptionist. And she can't get up and mess around like the rest of us.
是的，我必须用复印机装订巨大的文件。是的。我还是选椅子。会有卡纸。你必须把整个机器打开。但为珍娜辩护一下，是我在胡思乱想吗？珍娜在椅子上花了很多时间，因为她是接待员。她不能像我们其他人一样站起来到处走动。
As Pam. As Pam. Yes. That's right. As Jenna, I worked in offices and I had to use copiers all the time. And I still would pick chair. Wow. Do you remember the one super sh**ty chair that was on set?
作为帕姆。作为帕姆。是的。没错。作为珍娜，我在办公室工作，我必须一直使用复印机。但我还是会选椅子。哇。你还记得片场那把超级烂的椅子吗？
Yeah. Sometimes you would come to your desk and it would be at your chair. He'd be like, who the hell swapped? And then I would... It didn't have arms. It didn't have arms. And I would often get to set before Crete. And give it to Crete who wouldn't be able to tell the difference.
对。有时你会走到你的办公桌前，它就在你的椅子上。你会想，到底是谁换的？然后我会……它没有扶手。它没有扶手。我经常在克里特之前到达片场。把它给克里特，他根本分不出来。
I would scoched it over to Crete. Of course you did. Sometimes I'd watch them sit down and kind of look around like, huh? Poor Crete. And you know what? It would come back to accounting. Someone would move it around. But there should be a shit chair on the set.
我会把它挪到克里特那边。你当然会。有时我会看着他们坐下，然后环顾四周，心想，嗯？可怜的克里特。你知道吗？它会回到会计部。有人会把它挪来挪去。但片场应该有一把烂椅子。
There should be yes. Yes. And no one tells you. You just all figure it out. Just like an office. Just like an office. That's right. Well, I have this fun question from Ramona K in Ohio.
应该有，是的。是的。而且没人会告诉你。你们只是自己弄清楚了。就像办公室一样。就像办公室一样。没错。嗯，我有一个来自俄亥俄州拉莫娜·K的有趣问题。
I'll be the judge of that, Ramona. Ramona says, Dear Office ladies, my favorite Oscar scene is when he is waiting for Matt to come to the bar and he gets a little tipsy. He then plays basketball very poorly and it always makes me laugh so hard. Whenever Oscar plays drunk, it is hilarious. Thank you for making the best show and podcast ever. Oscar, did you love that scene? A follow-up is, did you have any tricks on playing drunk? It's not easy to play drunk.
我会来评判那个，拉莫娜。拉莫娜说，亲爱的办公室女士们，我最喜欢的奥斯卡场景是当他在酒吧等马特，然后喝得有点微醺的时候。他随后打篮球打得很烂，这总是让我笑得很大声。每当奥斯卡演醉酒时，都非常搞笑。谢谢你们制作了有史以来最好的节目和播客。奥斯卡，你喜欢那一幕吗？后续问题是，你有什么演醉酒的技巧吗？演醉酒并不容易。
It's not easy, Ramona. Thank you for that. I appreciate that because it's not easy to play drunk. You also had to play drunk when you went on the business trip where you guys call Angela. Also, you had to play drunk when you went to Robert California's house when you got super drunk on wine. That was super drunk. Wait, what are we learning about the character of Oscar right now? You're drunk quite a bit.
这不容易，拉莫娜。谢谢你，我很感激，因为演醉酒确实不容易。当你去商务旅行，你们给安吉拉打电话时，你也必须演醉酒。还有，当你去罗伯特·加利福尼亚家，喝了太多红酒时，你也必须演醉酒。那次是超级醉。等等，我们现在对奥斯卡这个角色了解到了什么？你喝醉的次数相当多。
He likes to twist off. Have you done drunk on the paper yet? No, not yet. Not yet. Within nine seasons. Yeah. That's a lot. I like the drunk that I was when I called.
他喜欢喝个痛快。你在《办公室》里演过醉酒了吗？不，还没。还没。在九季之内。对。那很多。我喜欢我打电话给你时那种醉酒的状态。
you. Yes. But at Robert's house, I was really drunk. Yeah. Yeah. That was a crazy episode. How do you do it? Yeah, the drunk, when Oscar and Andy call Angela, I thought that was like the perfect kind of drunk.
是的。但在罗伯特家，我真的喝醉了。对。对。那一集太疯狂了。你是怎么做到的？对，奥斯卡和安迪给安吉拉打电话时那种醉酒，我觉得那是完美的醉酒状态。
I did too. I agree. You still had some hills and valleys. Yeah, yeah. Wait, are you saying that's the drunk you would want to be? No, no, no. No, it's good to play. To play.
我也这么认为。我同意。你仍然有一些起伏。对，对。等等，你是说那是你想成为的醉酒状态吗？不，不，不。不，演起来很有趣。去演。
It's fun to play. That's the perfect drunk. When you're like still a little happy or a little buzzy. But you're a little spicy and you're a little spicy and you're a little spicy and you make really bad decisions. Yeah, like, oh, I love this ranking of the drunks. You know what? It is good.
演起来很有趣。那是完美的醉酒。当你仍然有点快乐或有点兴奋的时候。但你有点刻薄，你有点刻薄，你有点刻薄，你做出了非常糟糕的决定。对，就像，噢，我喜欢这个醉酒排名。你知道吗？这很好。
The drunk you don't want to be is the Robert California House drunk. That's like, you're not feeling good the next day. No, no, no, because anything could happen. That's not good. But I was just saying, like, I feel like you still had different choices you made at different times. That's right. Yeah. And that's when it's fun.
你不想成为的那种醉酒是罗伯特·加利福尼亚家里的那种醉酒。那种感觉就是，第二天你感觉不好。不，不，不，因为任何事情都可能发生。那不好。但我只是说，我觉得你仍然在不同时间做出了不同的选择。没错。对。而那才是最有趣的时候。
You think about being drunk, you think about when you've been drunk and then pull it way back. Pull it way back. Because if not, it gets weird. And you might not be able to pull it off. I've seen people who can't do good drunks And you're like, oh no And then I've seen people who play really good drugs
你想到醉酒，你想到你喝醉的时候，然后把它收回来。把它收回来。因为如果不这样，它会变得很奇怪。而且你可能无法成功。我见过那些演不好醉酒的人，你会想，噢，不。然后我也见过那些演得非常好的人。
I can't think of any off the top of my head Who else had to play drunk on our Just me? Oh, you know Surely there was someone else I had to do drunk at the Dundees Oh, that was like fall off a stool Yeah, but you were happy drunk
我一时想不出谁。还有谁必须在我们的节目里演醉酒？只有我吗？噢，你知道，肯定还有别人。我在邓迪奖颁奖礼上必须演醉酒。噢，那是那种从凳子上摔下来的。对，但你是快乐的醉酒。
That drunk was the same drunk that called you Yes, and also John, as Jim had to play drunk He drinks with Karen, he does shots Yeah, and then he falls off his bike. Yeah. That's right He's trying to bike home. That's right.
那种醉酒和给你打电话的那种醉酒是一样的。是的，还有约翰，吉姆必须演醉酒。他和凯伦喝酒，他喝了烈酒。对，然后他从自行车上摔了下来。对。没错。他试图骑车回家。没错。
Yeah, John does that well Well, he's from Boston And of course, I think We had a lot of drunk Meredith Oh gosh. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
对，约翰演得很好。嗯，他是波士顿人。当然，我想我们有很多醉酒的梅雷迪思。噢，天哪。对。对。对。
Yeah. Kate's seen with Michael when he's trying to get her to rehab And he's tackling her in the parking lot And she's like, wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute. Just amazing. And the whole thing of like taking a dog to the vet And he's like, we'll go into a bar
对。凯特和迈克尔的那一幕，当他试图带她去戒毒所时。他在停车场扑倒她。她说，等一下，等一下，等一下。简直太棒了。还有带狗去看兽医的那整件事，他说，我们要去酒吧。
And she's like, you just passed it. And he's like, this is the middle. And finally she gets it through her head. Oh, that's the best. Guys, I think we should take a quick break and we're going to come back. We have even more questions, Oscar. Will you stay with us? Oh, my Lord.
她说，你刚才经过了。他说，这是中间。最后她终于明白了。噢，那是最好的。伙计们，我觉得我们应该休息一下，然后我们会回来。我们还有更多问题，奥斯卡。你会留下来吗？噢，天哪。
Yes. Okay, great. Right, Oscar. Oh, my gosh. We are back. Oh, wait a second. We didn't take a break. What a fake out, you guys.
是的。好的，太棒了。对，奥斯卡。噢，天哪。我们回来了。噢，等一下。我们没休息。你们这些家伙，真是个骗局。
Do you want a break? The break was two seconds. I'm pulling the chair back. I'm like, time's a stretch. We can. No, it's okay. You can take it out. Keep going.
你们想要休息吗？休息只有两秒钟。我把椅子拉回来。我心想，时间很紧。我们可以。不，没关系。你可以把它剪掉。继续。
Keep going. This has nothing to do with your character. What do you do for fitness? You look fit. What do I do? I mean, you did hang upside down on the office. People have asked if you really did that and you really did that. I did.
继续。这和你的角色无关。你平时做什么健身？你看上去很健康。我做什么？我是说，你在《办公室》里确实倒挂过。人们问你是否真的那样做了，你确实那样做了。我做了。
I'm taking a little bit of martial arts, just a little bit, which I like. I've always done it off and on my whole life. What kind? What kind of martial arts? Right now it happens to be Hopkito. Okay. And yeah, I love it. I love it.
我正在学一点武术，只是一点点，我很喜欢。我一生中一直断断续续地在做。哪种？哪种武术？现在正好是合气道。好的。而且，是的，我喜欢它。我喜欢它。
And it's a little strange because this particular thing is two hours classes, which I've never done before. It's usually one hour, but this guy does two hours. So that's what we do. And I did it yesterday and I'll go tomorrow. Are you so wiped after? I mean, sometimes I play tennis for three hours. I'm a little wiped.
而且这有点奇怪，因为这个特定的课程是两小时的，我以前从未做过。通常是一小时，但这家伙做两小时。所以这就是我们做的。我昨天做了，明天还会去。你之后会很累吗？我是说，有时我打网球打三个小时。我会有点累。
That's a lot of, yeah. And also, I have a daughter, Jen and Angela, no, and she's in the school, and they were doing the importance of being earnest and so cute and adorable. And there was an intermission or whatever, it was over. And a dad walks in, this guy walks in. And his daughter's in the thing, too. and he walks and he comes up to me and he might be in his 40s
那很多，是的。而且，我有一个女儿，珍娜和安吉拉，不，她在学校，他们正在排练《认真的重要性》，太可爱太讨人喜欢了。中间有幕间休息什么的，结束了。一个爸爸走进来，这家伙走进来。他女儿也在里面。他走过来，走到我面前，他可能四十多岁。
and he's sweating and he's got like a backpack on and he takes it off in it. I can see it's heavy and I'm like, what are you doing? He's like, I'm like, you're hiking? It's like, no, it's a rucksack. It's a rucksack.
他满头大汗，背着个背包，他把它取下来，我能看出它很重，我心想，你在做什么？他说，我心想，你在徒步旅行？他说，不，这是个帆布背包。这是个帆布背包。
And it's like this camouflage backpack. And he says, it has weights in it. It comes and you put weights in and you walk with it. You're like hike with the backpack on it. It's like the women with the weighted vest. I see it everywhere.
就像那种迷彩背包。他说，里面有重量。它来了，你放进重量，然后背着它走路。你就像是背着背包徒步。就像那些穿着负重背心的女性。我到处都能看到。
Yeah, but it's a backpack. Okay. And he proceeds to pitch this thing to me. He's very excited about it. By the way, it was 50 pounds. I can barely lift it. I'm like, what is going on? He's like, yep.
对，但这是个背包。好的。然后他开始向我推销这个东西。他对此非常兴奋。顺便说一句，它有50磅重。我几乎提不动。我心想，这是怎么回事？他说，是的。
And I like, hey, man, and I put my hand on the shoulder, and he felt like a rock. And he proceeded to speak for 30 minutes straight about this thing he's doing. So we get home and I'm like, Ursula, order me a rucksack, 20 pounds to start. And I don't know why, but now I'm doing it. You are? So people who are listening, they know it. And it's all, you know, bros do it. And men who are taking too much testosterone in their 60s.
我心想，嘿，伙计，我把手放在他肩膀上，他感觉像块石头。他接着说了整整30分钟关于他正在做的这件事。所以我们回到家，我心想，厄休拉，给我订个帆布背包，先从20磅开始。我不知道为什么，但现在我在做了。你真的在做？所以听众们，他们知道了。而且，你知道，兄弟们都这么做。还有那些60多岁摄入过多睾酮的男人们。
And they put this thing on and it's all camouflage and black and flags. Oscar, we buy everything. I bought it. I bought it. I bought everything. I have the weighted vest. Jenna, this morning. No, lady, this made me laugh so hard this morning.
他们穿上这个东西，全是迷彩、黑色和旗帜。奥斯卡，我们什么都买。我买了。我买了。我买了所有东西。我有负重背心。珍娜，今天早上。不，女士，这今天早上让我笑得很大声。
This is so funny. I was on the gram today and I got fed this thing. It is a neck massager that is supposed. going to tighten my jaw and jowls. So I want to read our text exchange this morning, okay? This is my first text to Angela this morning. If you speak about it for 10 more minutes, I will buy it. This is at 9.47 a.m. I just bought a neck massager off Instagram that is supposed to make your jawline look tighter without surgery. I, in my pajamas, pick it up because I've bought it, but she doesn't know. I take a selfie and I say, you mean this one that I bought
这太搞笑了。我今天在Instagram上，我被推送了这个东西。这是一个颈部按摩器，说是要紧致我的下巴和赘肉。所以我想读一下我们今天早上的短信交流，好吗？这是我今天早上给安吉拉的第一条短信。如果你再多说10分钟，我就买了。这是在上午9点47分。我刚在Instagram上买了一个颈部按摩器，说是不用手术就能让你的下巴线条看起来更紧致。我，穿着睡衣，把它拿起来，因为我已经买了，但她不知道。我自拍了一张，我说，你是说我上个月买的这个吗？
last month. Fish in a barrel, ladies and gentlemen. Same exact one. Send the office ladies. Jenna says, whatever crap, they'll buy it and put it on their bodies. And me too. I shouldn't.
瓮中捉鳖，女士们先生们。完全一样。发送给办公室女士们。珍娜说，不管什么垃圾，她们都会买下来放在身上。我也是。我不该买的。
Gina goes, oh my God, did it work? I said, no, but you do get a very deep sort of shoulder massage. It's kind of painful for me. She goes, have you been doing it every day? I said, no. Also, it doesn't really fit my neck. Josh is able to get a great neck rub out of it, but my neck is too small, so instead it just squeezes the shit out of my shoulder.
吉娜说，噢，天哪，它管用吗？我说，不，但你确实能得到一种非常深层的肩部按摩。对我来说有点疼。她说，你每天都在用吗？我说，不。而且，它不太适合我的脖子。乔什能用它得到很好的颈部按摩，但我的脖子太小了，所以它只会把我的肩膀挤得要死。
So how did you hear about this? It got fed to me on Instagram. Same with me, and I didn't tell you, but I had already bought it. I wish I texted you first. But I thought, surely I'll be the first one to try it. You took a chance. You took a chance. Let's get back to some fan questions here.
那你怎么听说这个的？它在Instagram上推送给我的。我也是，我没告诉你，但我已经买了。我希望我先给你发短信。但我心想，肯定我是第一个尝试的人。你冒了个险。你冒了个险。让我们回到一些粉丝问题。
Oscar, you are a famous member of the Finer Things Club. It's so fun. The paper, you start making puzzles for the newspaper. I mean, you win a whole award in the last episode for your puzzles. Are you into either of these things in real life? Books or puzzles. I'm into books. I'm into puzzles, too, but I'm more into books than puzzles.
奥斯卡，你是“美好事物俱乐部”的著名成员。太有趣了。报纸，你开始为报纸制作拼图。我是说，你在最后一集中因为你的拼图赢得了整个奖项。你在现实生活中对这两件事感兴趣吗？书或拼图。我对书感兴趣。我也对拼图感兴趣，但我对书比对拼图更感兴趣。
But the Finders Things Club, isn't it also art and the appreciation of art? It is. It's a book club, too. I feel like it's mainly a book club. I think so, too, because we discussed the books. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, what are some books that you are liking right now?
但“美好事物俱乐部”，难道不也是关于艺术和对艺术的欣赏吗？是的。它也是个读书俱乐部。我觉得它主要是读书俱乐部。我也这么认为，因为我们讨论了书。对。对。对，你现在喜欢哪些书？
Oh, I'm always... Or that you've liked recently. Oh, let me see. I'm reading because I'm flying hither and thither. And I have Dave Sedaris's new book, which is always good. I love David Sedaris. Yeah, he's very funny. And it's easy for flights and stuff because it's short stories.
噢，我总是……或者你最近喜欢的。噢，让我看看。我在阅读，因为我飞来飞去。我有戴夫·塞达里斯的新书，那总是很好。我喜欢大卫·塞达里斯。对，他非常有趣。而且它很适合飞行什么的，因为它是短篇故事。
We were in Limerick Island, and I picked up an Agatha Christie book just because I was there. I love it. It's a murder mystery. It's very silly and funny. And I'll try to pass it on to August when I'm done with it. Well, we thought this was a really good question from Megan B from Silver Springs, Maryland. That's kind of a thinking question, Oscar. I like Marlon.
我们在利默里克岛，我随手拿了一本阿加莎·克里斯蒂的书，只是因为我在那儿。我喜欢它。这是一个谋杀悬疑故事。它非常傻而且有趣。等我读完后，我会试着把它传给奥古斯特。嗯，我们觉得这是来自马里兰州银泉市的梅根·B的一个非常好的问题。那是个思考题，奥斯卡。我喜欢马龙。
Megan says, why is Oscar at Dunder Mifflin for so long? Throughout the series, he seems to gain confidence and outspokenness and is clearly one of the more capable employees at the branch. So did Oscar have a backstory for staying? Oscar is unique and also the same as everyone else. Why do people stay where they are? They get complacent. They get comfortable.
梅根说，为什么奥斯卡在邓德·米夫林待了这么久？在整个系列中，他似乎获得了自信和直言不讳，显然是分部里更有能力的员工之一。那么奥斯卡留下来有什么背景故事吗？奥斯卡是独特的，也和每个人一样。为什么人们待在他们所在的地方？他们变得自满。他们变得舒适。
You have a job every year. so you get a raise. Why take a chance? Why go somewhere else? Know the devil you're with whatever that saying is. He's got friends. He's established. He's not 20. He's not 19. He's done. He's comfortable. Yeah. If he went hunting, if something horrible happened, he's like, I got to get out of here. Then he'd get a resume and get a headhunter and do all that stuff that you have to do to find a good job somewhere else that's comparable. You don't want to go backwards. Yeah. And also, in this day and age, you're going to leave and go looking for a job and you're up against 20-year-olds and stuff? Yeah, at that age. That's very true. You sort of hit a plateau and you're like, well, I've got a good thing.
你每年都有工作，所以你会加薪。为什么要冒险？为什么要到别处去？了解你所处的魔鬼，无论那句谚语是什么。他有朋友。他已经立足了。他不是20岁。他不是19岁。他完成了。他很舒服。对。如果他去打猎，如果发生了什么可怕的事情，他心想，我得离开这里。然后他会准备一份简历，找个猎头，做所有你必须做的事情，去别处找一份相当的好工作。你不想走回头路。对。而且，在当今时代，你要离开去寻找工作，而你面对的是20岁的人等等？对，在这个年纪。那非常真实。你有点触及了平台期，你心想，嗯，我有个好东西。
Jobs aren't easy to come by. We did have a fun fan catch from Savannah Ellen, Virginia, who said this. During suit warehouse, Oscar can be seen typing an email to the New York Post. I paused to read the email and it said, quote, this would be the perfect job for me. So she spotted an instance of you may be being interested in working. at a paper before the paper. What's her name? Who is it? Savannah. Savannah from Virginia. Savannah, you should be a PI. I don't know what is happening. You have proof of me typing for another job? Yes, that this would be the perfect job for me. And what I love about this is that there are always these moments. In our rewatch of watching the office, there would be some little thing that is background, that is like, nothing.
工作不容易找到。我们确实有一个来自弗吉尼亚州萨凡纳·艾伦的有趣粉丝发现，她说这个。在“西装仓库”期间，可以看到奥斯卡在给《纽约邮报》写电子邮件。我暂停阅读了那封邮件，上面写着，引用，“这将是我的完美工作。”所以她发现了一个你可能在纸业之前就有兴趣在报社工作的例子。她叫什么名字？是谁？萨凡纳。来自弗吉尼亚的萨凡纳。萨凡纳，你应该当私家侦探。我不知道发生了什么。你有我申请另一份工作的证据？是的，这对我来说是完美的工作。我喜欢这一点的是，总是有这些时刻。在我们重看《办公室》时，会有一些背景里的小东西，就像，没什么。
nothing of significance that the writers wrote or that you see on our desk. And then later there's a whole storyline. And fans will write in and say, was that foreshadowing? Did they know five years before that Jim was going to play guitar or whatever it was? And the answer is no. But I think somewhere the answer is yes. We have to get. Somewhere.
没什么意义，是编剧写的，或者你在我们的桌子上看到的。然后后来有一个完整的故事线。粉丝们会写信说，那是伏笔吗？他们五年前就知道吉姆会弹吉他还是什么的吗？答案是否定的。但我认为在某个地方答案是肯定的。我们必须得到。在某个地方。
We have to get the savannas of this country and the world together and throw them a parade because this is insane. Isn't that amazing? They take a picture and they're like, this happened. Savannah, good for you. I don't know. I don't even remember this. I think there is something about this creative group mind,
我们必须把这个国家的萨凡纳们和世界各地的人聚在一起，为他们举行游行，因为这太疯狂了。那不是很神奇吗？他们拍了一张照片，他们心想，这发生了。萨凡纳，为你点赞。我不知道。我甚至不记得这个了。我想这个创意群体思维里有些东西，
how sometimes you put something in the universe or in the universe of the show, whether it be writers or crew or performers. And without you even realizing it, it starts to inform you. Like, I remember Rain as Dwight opening up his desk drawer and setting up his desk for the day and he's doing little drummer boy. Remember? Yes. And then all those years later,
有时你把某样东西放进宇宙或节目的宇宙里，无论是编剧、剧组还是表演者。而你甚至没有意识到，它就开始影响你。比如，我记得雷恩饰演的德怀特打开他的办公桌抽屉，为这一天整理他的办公桌，他在做小鼓手。记得吗？是的。然后多年以后，
then Angelus sings that particular song at the Christmas party. So it's just those little moments. Yeah, but that wasn't like consciously in the writer's heads at all. No, no. But it seeps in, right? Like somewhere someone had this idea that Oscar might like to work at a paper. Yeah. And they created this prop for you.
然后安吉拉在圣诞派对上唱了那首歌。所以这只是那些小瞬间。对，但这根本不是编剧脑子里有意识的。不，不。但它渗进来了，对吧？就像在某个地方有人有这个想法，奥斯卡可能喜欢在报社工作。对。他们为你创造了这个道具。
And now here you are on the paper. Which brings me to this question. Rachel Y in Spring Lake Michigan said, what do you think happened to Oscar in between the finale of the office and the pilot of the paper? If my math is correct, there is an approximately 12-year gap. Rachel would like to believe that you were just an involved godfather to Philip for most of the intervening years. And then also, Kristen C from Somerville, South Carolina said, what is your story for how you ended up at the paper?
现在你就在报社了。这让我想到了这个问题。密歇根州斯普林湖的瑞秋·Y说，你认为奥斯卡在《办公室》结局和《报社》试播集之间发生了什么？如果我的数学没错，大约有12年的差距。瑞秋想相信，在中间的大部分时间里，你只是菲利普的一位参与其中的教父。然后还有，南卡罗来纳州萨默维尔的克里斯汀·C说，你关于你是如何最终进入报社的故事是什么？
Like, how did you get to Toledo? Rachel, I think it's 12 years, but I think in the paper they made it four? I think, am I wrong? So you stayed working at Dunder Mifflin after the finale, even though you were going to become a state senator. You think that didn't happen? I think he lost. He must have lost the election.
比如，你是怎么去托莱多的？瑞秋，我觉得是12年，但我觉得在《报社》里他们设定为四年？我想，我错了吗？所以你在结局后继续在邓德·米夫林工作，尽管你要成为州参议员。你认为那没发生？我想他输了。他一定输掉了选举。
So he stayed at under Mifflin. And then got scooped up. Oh, right. Yeah. When the company was bought out. Yeah. And he just continued that same desk job and followed it to Toledo. Yeah.
所以他留在了邓德·米夫林。然后被挖走了。噢，对。对。当公司被收购时。对。他只是继续那份同样的办公桌工作，并跟随它去了托莱多。对。
Yeah. That's what happened. I think they probably got offered more money. He's like, Toledo Scranton. Eh. And he went to Toledo. I mean, he's kind of a workaholic. And for all his whatever, whatever, he played.
对。这就是发生的事情。我想他们可能得到了更多的钱。他心想，托莱多，斯克兰顿。呃。然后他去了托莱多。我是说，他有点工作狂。而且尽管他怎么样怎么样，他玩了。
He plays it pretty safe. Yeah. He's pretty conservative guy. There's people like that. I have a cousin like that. Very by the book. Very smart. A doctorate.
他玩得很安全。对。他是个相当保守的人。有这样的人。我有个表亲就是那样。非常按部就班。非常聪明。博士学位。
But will not bend a rule if you paid her a billion dollars. Yeah. And he's kind of like that. He's comfortable with that company. Yeah, he's a little boring, too. He thinks of himself as sophisticated and whatever, but kind of a little boring. Right? He is.
但如果你给她十亿美元，她也不会打破规则。对。他有点像那样。他很适应那家公司。对，他也有点无聊。他认为自己很老练什么的，但有点无聊。对吧？他是。
He's very conservative, isn't he? He is. He is very conservative. Yeah. He's not a big risk taker. No, he's not a big risk taker. Finder Things Club. That's the risk. Look at us. We're in barraise. Yeah. We're in berets and whatever. Okay. We have this question from Caitlin P. and Wakeman, Ohio. And Caitlin wants you to know that's an hour east of Toledo. I thought so. And she says, this is not so much a question, but my office loving heart needs to let Oscar know how much I love his reaction to Michael's sad scarecrow that he gives him before he leaves and how Michael then loses his.
他非常保守，不是吗？他是。他非常保守。对。他不是个大冒险家。不，他不是个大冒险家。美好事物俱乐部。那是冒险。看看我们。我们戴着贝雷帽。对。我们戴着贝雷帽什么的。好的。我们有来自俄亥俄州韦克曼的凯特琳·P的这个问题。凯特琳想让你知道，那是托莱多以东一小时路程。我想也是。她说，这与其说是一个问题，不如说是我热爱办公室的心需要让奥斯卡知道，我有多喜欢他对迈克尔在他离开前给他的悲伤稻草人的反应，以及迈克尔随后失去了……
mind because he knows it's terrible. So it made my heart extremely happy when I saw that Oscar still has it on his desk at the paper. Why do you think Oscar brought it with him? Because that's from his boss. And, you know, let's face it, all the people at Dunder Mifflin, they're friends. And Michael drives him crazy or whatever, but they'd be the first to be there if he gets a broken leg and is at the hospital. Guess who's going to visit him? His co-workers. Yeah. Yeah. Oscar and everyone. even Toby would show up. I mean, I'm a bunch of this thing. I don't like it, Toby.
理智，因为他知道这很糟糕。所以当我看到奥斯卡在报社的桌子上还有它时，我的心感到非常快乐。你为什么觉得奥斯卡把它带在身边？因为那是他老板给的。而且，你知道，面对现实吧，邓德·米夫林的所有人，他们是朋友。迈克尔让他发疯什么的，但如果他腿断了在医院，他们会是第一个到场的人。猜猜谁会去看他？他的同事。对。对。奥斯卡和每个人。甚至托比也会出现。我是说，我讨厌这个东西。我不喜欢它，托比。
I'm allergic to daisies or whatever. And then he'd say something weirdly nice about him after he left. They're like family. Yeah. Yeah. I think so. That's why he has it there. My old boss.
我对雏菊什么的过敏。然后他离开后会说一些奇怪的好话。他们就像家人一样。对。对。我想是这样。这就是为什么他把它放在那儿。我的老老板。
Shelby B. from St. Charles, Missouri, said, Oscar has such a distinctive dance style. He shows it off at Jim and Pam's wedding. And also during the dance, the whole office does to Boogie Wonderland in season nine. it's sort of like a robot, but with more flair. I was just wondering, where did the idea for this dance style come from? And how did Oscar think it fit in with his character's backstory? Well, he's gay.
密苏里州圣查尔斯的谢尔比·B说，奥斯卡有一种独特的舞蹈风格。他在吉姆和帕姆的婚礼上展示了它。还有在第九季全办公室跳的《Boogie Wonderland》期间。它有点像机器人，但更有天赋。我只是想知道，这种舞蹈风格的想法是从哪里来的？奥斯卡认为它与他角色的背景故事有什么契合之处？嗯，他是同性恋。
Okay. And he's that age. And for those fellas, there's only one. And her name is Madonna. Oh, he's doing vogue. The vogue. He's voguing. He's vogging.
好的。而且他是那个年纪。对于那些家伙来说，只有一个。她的名字叫麦当娜。噢，他在跳Vogue。Vogue。他在跳Vogue。他在跳Vogue。
Yes. Come on invoke. Yes, that's exactly what he's doing. And that video is back. Bad ass in black and white with those gay Puerto Ricans, Vogueing with the wind in their hair, and they got the attitude. Yeah, and she has that badass. Yeah, man, this is the best.
是的。来吧，Vogue。是的，那正是他在做的。那段视频又回来了。黑白色的坏蛋，和那些波多黎各同性恋一起，跳着Vogue，头发在风中飘扬，他们有那种态度。对，她有那种坏蛋。对，伙计，这是最好的。
You are so right. That's his version. He's not great at it. No, he's not 20 years old anymore. But he remembers. He remembers. His whole heart. He's doing the dance theory.
你说得太对了。那是他的版本。他跳得并不好。不，他不再是20岁了。但他记得。他记得。他的全心全意。他在跳舞蹈理论。
That's right. We've talked about this before on the podcast, but the three of us have been known to close down a dance floor. Well, one particular dance. This is true. I was just talking about the off. Beyonce. Beyonce. All the single ladies.
没错。我们之前在播客上谈过这个，但我们三个以关掉舞池而闻名。嗯，一场特定的舞蹈。这是真的。我刚才在谈论那个。碧昂丝。碧昂丝。所有单身女士。
That's a long time ago. Yeah. That's how long we've been. Yeah. You guys. And you are a very, very good dancer. I literally was in Studio 54. I went to Studio 54 at 17 years of age.
那是很久以前的事了。对。这就是我们在一起的时间。对。你们。而且你是一个非常，非常好的舞者。我真的在54号工作室。我17岁时去了54号工作室。
The Studio 54. Not a lot. I got in once or twice. That's amazing. I would have to go in with Eddie, my cousin. I couldn't go in by. myself. I'd be out there waiting like an idiot all night. I wouldn't get any. Would you dance?
54号工作室。不多。我进去过一两次。那太神奇了。我必须和我的表亲埃迪一起进去。我不能自己进去。我会像个白痴一样在外面等一整晚。我什么也得不到。你会跳舞吗？
Oh, yeah. Studio 54? Yeah. But I only went once or twice. Yeah. We used to go to the limelight or infinity. We can get into there. The only way I got into Studio 54 was if Eddie was with me, my older cousin. Well, when we do, Beyonce's all the single ladies, we should mention that you do take the lead. You are the center. You are the center. You are the center and we follow you. Now, Jenna's a really good dancer. As it should be, we all are, you guys. Let's not fight. I am, listen, I'm not fine.
噢，是的。54号工作室？对。但我只去过一两次。对。我们过去常去Limelight或Infinity。我们可以进去。我进入54号工作室的唯一方法是如果埃迪和我在一起，我的大表亲。嗯，当我们跳碧昂丝的《所有单身女士》时，我们应该提到你确实带头。你是中心。你是中心。你是中心，我们跟着你。现在，珍娜是个非常好的舞者。理应如此，我们都是，你们这些家伙。别吵了。我是，听着，我没吵。
You guys are actually good dancers. I have to follow you and like kind of count in my head. But I, you know what? Jen and I are looking at each other and not. I'm not saying that we have to do this, but I feel like maybe before we leave, we should video ourselves. This could be horrible. It might be bad. Maybe it will never see the light a day.
你们实际上是很好的舞者。我必须跟着你们，在脑子里数拍子。但我，你知道吗？珍娜和我在看着对方，不。我不是说我们必须这样做，但我觉得也许在我们离开之前，我们应该录下我们自己。这可能会很糟糕。可能会很烂。也许它永远不会见天日。
Oh my gosh. Maybe for one. I mean, who knows when the three of us will get a chance to do Beyonce, all the single ladies. No, we will. at a party. Oh, let's do it. In private. I don't know if we should put it out there. Go ahead. You want to film it? Go ahead and see what it looks like. I don't know. One day, one day we're going to do it again. No, we should go. We should have a party somewhere. Let's be glammed up. Well, speaking of your dancing, many people also wrote in saying how much they love you in the proposal. This is another dance scene. 20 years ago. Oscar. People will say, do that now. I'm like, no. I'm not going to do that now. Oscar, you're so funny in that movie. 20 years ago.
噢，天哪。也许为了一个。我是说，谁知道我们三个什么时候有机会跳碧昂丝的《所有单身女士》。不，我们会跳的。在派对上。噢，我们跳吧。私下里。我不知道我们是否应该把它放出来。继续。你想拍下来吗？继续看看它看起来怎么样。我不知道。有一天，有一天我们会再跳一次。不，我们应该去。我们应该在某个地方开个派对。让我们打扮得漂漂亮亮的。嗯，说到你的舞蹈，很多人也写信说他们有多喜欢你在《求婚》里的表现。这是另一个舞蹈场景。20年前。奥斯卡。人们会说，现在做那个。我心想，不。我现在不会做那个。奥斯卡，你在那部电影里太搞笑了。20年前。
I want you to know we got a lot of mail for you for this episode. People were very excited that you're coming on the podcast. 50% of it was about the proposal. She's not kidding. It was a great role. It's a good rom-com. People want us to watch it on Office Lady 6.0 and break it down and then have you back on to tell us behind-the-scenes stories.
我想让你知道，我们为你收到了很多关于这一集的邮件。人们非常兴奋你要来参加播客。50%的内容是关于《求婚》的。她没开玩笑。那是个很棒的角色。那是一部很好的浪漫喜剧。人们希望我们在《办公室女士6.0》上观看它并进行拆解，然后让你回来告诉我们幕后故事。
Sure. Oh, great. That's a date. By the way, for those of you who probably everyone knows this, I'm not saying anything, but as talented as Sandra Bullock is, that's how nice a person she is. I can't speak enough of her. She's a wonderful, wonderful kid. Well, you'll have to come back because I haven't seen that movie since it came out.
当然。噢，太棒了。那是个约定。顺便说一句，对于那些可能每个人都知道这一点的人，我不是在说什么，但桑德拉·布洛克有多才华，她就是个多好的人。我怎么夸她都不为过。她是个很棒，很棒的孩子。嗯，你得回来，因为那部电影自从上映后我就没看过。
I have watched it since because it is one of my favorite rom-coms. Oh, and man, we went to see Steve in a 40-year-old Virgin, and you guys came out to see me in the proposal. Those were haddy times. That was fun while we were on the office. And the thing is, you didn't tell us, and well, wait, we'll wait until you come back on to break it down with us. Because there was a moment when we were all at the premiere that I just remember being like, ah! Well, Laura was really, she kept looking at me like, Oscar, I'm like, that's what I do. I don't know what you thought I was.
我看过，因为它是我最喜欢的浪漫喜剧之一。噢，伙计，我们去看史蒂夫演的《四十岁的老处男》，你们来看我演的《求婚》。那些是美好的时光。我们在《办公室》时那很有趣。问题是，你没告诉我们，嗯，好吧，我们会等你回来和我们一起拆解它。因为当我们都在首映式上时，有一个时刻我记得就像是，啊！嗯，劳拉确实，她一直看着我，就像，奥斯卡，我心想，这就是我做的。我不知道你以为我是什么。
Yeah. I was in the ground wings. I knew that side of you. You knew me. You knew that apart of me. But a lot of people didn't. Well, that's the cool thing about you as a performer, Oscar. And I know you were saying that you love doing the paper because you play the straight man, but you do also play the funny guy.
对。我在地面侧翼。我知道你的那一面。你了解我。你了解我的那一部分。但很多人不知道。嗯，这就是你作为表演者很酷的地方，奥斯卡。我知道你说你喜欢做《报社》，因为你演直男，但你也演搞笑的人。
Oh, I love it. You can do both things really well, which is unusual. Thank you. Yeah, I love comedy. Yeah. I love it. Love it. Well, before we go, can you tell us a little bit about what we can expect on season two of the paper?
噢，我喜欢它。你可以很好地做这两件事，这很不寻常。谢谢。对，我喜欢喜剧。对。我喜欢它。喜欢它。嗯，在我们走之前，你能告诉我们一点关于《报社》第二季我们可以期待什么吗？
Oh, I think it's funnier than season one. But the relationships keep changing and we have some really funny guest guy who comes on and he's in an office somewhere else. I don't know if I'm allowed to say who he is. Oh, that's fine. I like that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You'll find out who he is soon enough. And it's really good.
噢，我觉得它比第一季更有趣。但关系一直在变，我们有一些非常有趣的客串家伙，他出现在别处的办公室里。我不知道我是否被允许说他是谁。噢，没关系。我喜欢那个。对，对，对。你很快就会知道他是谁了。而且它真的很好。
I like the first season. I think the second season is funnier. And Jenna just informed me it's coming out today. Yeah. So in the finale, your character, he wins this award at the Ohio Journalism Awards. And when you accept your award, you dedicate it to the documentary film crew, who up until this point you have been annoyed with. You're annoyed that they showed up this new place.
我喜欢第一季。我觉得第二季更有趣。珍娜刚通知我它今天出来。对。所以在结局中，你的角色，他在俄亥俄州新闻奖上赢得了这个奖项。当你领奖时，你把它献给了纪录片摄制组，直到这一点你一直对他们感到恼火。你很恼火他们出现在这个新地方。
So is your character more open to participating in season two? I think, yeah. I mean, you can't hit that note forever about, I don't want to be filmed. But at some point, at some point, right? You're like, I have to be okay with this. You're going to give yourself an ulcer as the character. Yes. Yeah.
所以你的角色在第二季更愿意参与了吗？我想，是的。我是说，你不能永远纠结于那个，我不想被拍摄。但在某个时刻，在某个时刻，对吧？你心想，我必须接受这个。你会作为角色给自己造成溃疡。是的。对。
But I like that they showed a little passage of time there where he got used to it. Of course. Because then as the audience, now I believe it, I'm on board. I get why he's softening. And it's funny to be like, oh, no, where do you guys, you know, all that stuff. Gosh, if you had been followed for nine years and you finally shook that and then you saw them walk in the door again, what other reaction could you have? You're like, what is happening? Yes.
但我喜欢他们展示了一点时间流逝，他习惯了。当然。因为作为观众，现在我相信了，我加入了。我明白他为什么软化了。而且很有趣，就像，噢，不，你们这些家伙，你知道，所有那些东西。天哪，如果你被跟踪了九年，你终于摆脱了它，然后你又看到他们走进门，你还能有什么反应？你心想，发生了什么？是的。
Yeah. Amazing. Oscar, this is just so fun seeing you because we just love you. And, you know, I was recently asked a fan question, what was some of my most meaningful scenes to do in the office and the most fun I had and my favorite scene partner. and I said, obviously, I loved working with everyone on the office, but my favorite scene partner was getting to do all of those scenes with Oscar and us, just the journey our two characters went on. And I'm so proud of that.
是啊。太棒了。奥斯卡，见到你真是太开心了，因为我们真的很喜欢你。你知道，最近有人问我一个粉丝问题，问我在《办公室》里拍过哪些最有意义的场景，我玩得最开心的是哪次，还有我最喜欢的搭档是谁。我说，显然，我喜欢和《办公室》里的每个人合作，但我最喜欢的搭档是和奥斯卡一起拍的所有那些场景，以及我们两个角色所经历的旅程。我对此感到非常自豪。
Thank you. That relationship, and you're so good. And I think the only reason that I was able to do that is because of you, what you gave me as a scene partner. And you are one of the reasons I think, Angela, Lamarton didn't just stay one note. You know, your character's storyline brought so much out of my character and helped me discover new things about my character.
谢谢。那段关系，而且你演得太好了。我想我能做到这一点，唯一的原因就是因为你，因为你作为搭档给予我的东西。安吉拉，我认为你是让马丁这个角色没有流于平面的原因之一。你知道，你角色的故事线激发了我角色的很多潜能，也帮助我发现了自己角色身上的一些新东西。
And you're just so talented. Thank you. Right back at you. And again, the writers gave us that opportunity making those stories. But, I mean, seeing you on the set, people don't know. We've known each other like you were working at a 1-800 thing. And I was away. And we were doing-
你真的太有才华了。谢谢。你也一样。再说一次，是编剧给了我们机会去创作那些故事。但是，我是说，在片场看到你，人们不知道。我们认识很久了，就像你当时在一家1-800电话公司工作一样。而我当时不在。我们当时在做——
We were doing improv, you guys. be at the theater, like hearing L.A., wearing stupid wigs and stuff, and then to be on the same set and not know it. Yeah. That's like, and then on top of that, Ed and Brian going to the same high school and many people were at the same university, but you and I knew each other here working, and to meet there is pretty magical. Yeah.
我们当时在做即兴表演，伙计们。在剧院里，就像在洛杉矶听到的那样，戴着愚蠢的假发之类的，然后能在同一个片场相遇却不知道。是的。那就像，再加上艾德和布莱恩上了同一所高中，很多人上了同一所大学，但你和我是在这里工作时认识的，能在那里相遇真是太神奇了。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. And we still know each other. And we still know each other. Yeah. That's one of my favorite storylines. And, you know, people ask us a lot. What was it like when Steve left?
是啊。是啊。而且我们现在还认识。我们依然了解彼此。是啊。那是我最喜欢的故事线之一。而且，你知道，人们经常问我们。史蒂夫离开的时候是什么感觉？
And your storyline is an example of, I think, something that we got maybe because the character of Michael Scott left and they went to our deep bench of talent. Yeah. And they wrote really great storylines for characters that before when we had this very much lead character, those second two seasons of the office, there wasn't like a single lead of the show anymore like there had been before. And I actually thought that was a really smart way to handle it. But instead, we got these really cool storylines that, I mean, it gives me chills some of your scenes together. I just absolutely love it. And I think it's one of the highlights of those later seasons.
我认为你们的故事线就是一个例子，我们之所以能得到这些，可能是因为迈克尔·斯科特这个角色离开了，他们转向了我们深厚的人才储备。是的。他们为那些角色写了非常棒的故事线，而在之前我们有这个非常核心的主角时，在《办公室》的最后两季里，不再像以前那样有一个单一的主角了。我其实觉得这是一种非常聪明的处理方式。相反，我们得到了这些非常酷的故事线，我是说，你们在一起的一些场景让我起鸡皮疙瘩。我绝对太喜欢了。我认为这是后期几季的亮点之一。
Aw, thanks, lady. And the thing that was done, for all the hilarity of the show, when you have scenes like us, like, you know, hey, come live with me. And Jenna saying by to Steve at the airport. and we don't hear what they're saying, those are really cool moments. That's really, really beautiful deep stuff.
噢，谢谢你，女士。而且，尽管这部剧充满了欢笑，但当你拥有像我们这样的场景时，比如，嘿，来和我住吧。还有珍娜在机场和史蒂夫告别，我们听不到他们在说什么，那些都是非常酷的时刻。那是非常、非常美丽而深刻的东西。
Yeah. You know, and Craig and Amy and Steve driving to wherever Colorado and the truck when he's going with her. Those are really emotional. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊。你知道，还有克雷格、艾米和史蒂夫开车去科罗拉多或其他什么地方，当他带着她时，在卡车里的场景。那些真的非常感人。是啊，是啊，是啊。
Amazing. These are beautiful things. And you're like, wow. Oscar, thank you so much for coming. You're welcome. Thank you, Oscar. Going down memory lane with us.
太棒了。这些都是美好的事情。你会觉得，哇。奥斯卡，非常感谢你的到来。不客气。谢谢你，奥斯卡。和我们一起重温往事。
It was wonderful. I don't know the specific. What's the fee? What's the payment? What do I... I didn't get any... We will send it. Seriously, I love you guys.
这太美妙了。我不清楚具体情况。报酬是多少？付款方式是什么？我该……我没收到任何……我们会寄给你的。说真的，我爱你们。
This was so much fun. I'll come back anytime. It was great. Thanks, Oscar. I love you. Well, thank you so much to Oscar for coming in the studio with us and hanging out. You know, we have talked to him before on the podcast,
这太有趣了。我随时都会再来。太棒了。谢谢，奥斯卡。我爱你。好吧，非常感谢奥斯卡来到我们的演播室和我们一起闲逛。你知道，我们之前在播客上和他聊过，
but it was over Zoom. So having him here was just so special. Really special. And everyone, be sure to check out the Paper Season 2, which is now streaming on Peacock. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
但那是通过Zoom进行的。所以能让他亲自来到这里真是太特别了。真的非常特别。还有大家，一定要去看看《纸》第二季，现在正在Peacock上播出。我们下周见。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。